In my time...
Sorry, I forgot it was completely playing.
In
my time...
Here, I'll start.
We'll listen to it in its entirety.
Once it...
restarts.
Welcome back!
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid 3.
Subsistence.
Last time I left off, we had just met Eva.
And... my game froze.
But my save seems to be...
okay.
Last I checked.
So...
Um...
Yeah, I'm ready to go...
for it.
And...
So yeah, I'll make multiple saves this time.
Yeah.
The save is saved.
Thanks to...
No one.
This is not... nope.
No one gets the credit.
Did you press R1?
Absolutely.
Yeah, Eva's just too sexy.
My...
My PS2, like...
crumpled under her, you know?
Happy first day of fall!
Oh my gosh!
First day of fall...
You guys can hear it, by the way, right?
What is this?
What a thrill...
I'm searching, and I'll melt into you...
What a fear in my heart...
But you're so supreme...
I give my life...
Not for honor, but...
The way it shows, um...
In my time...
There'll be no one
else...
Crime...
Is the way...
I fly to you...
I'm still...
In a dream...
Snake eater...
Love...
Someday...
You go...
Through the rain...
And someday...
What do you feed on?
On a tree...
A tree frog!
It's ordeal...
The trial...
To survive...
For the day...
We see new light...
I give my life...
Not for honor, but for...
Snake eater...
In my time...
Time...
There'll be no one else...
Crime...
Is the way...
I fly to you...
I'm still...
In a dream...
Snake eater...
I'm still...
In a dream...
Snake eater...
Daga...
Dang it, I didn't get the sneeter.
I'll keep trying for the sneeter.
Okay, that was good.
That was good.
Good warm-up session everybody.
Now we're orange.
Before it was pink.
It was so cute.
Best game track so... this is too good.
All Metal Gear songs are just... they're just too good.
I'm gonna press the start button so it doesn't replay because then we'll have to do it all over again.
Yeah.
Sorry if you're watching live, which is right now.
Hello.
If you're watching the VOD, maybe this doesn't really pertain to you.
But I wanted to apologize because I was supposed to play this on Saturday.
Now I'm playing it on Sunday.
So it's Metal Gear Sunday instead of Saturday.
I'm so sorry for that.
VOD watches skip 10 minutes possibly.
What?
You don't want to hear me yop!
I wasn't feeling so hot yesterday.
When I woke up, I was like...
But I'm feeling good now.
Actually, I think it was like so much stress.
I haven't been able to sleep very well recently because I've been like...
My brain has been just like... going and going.
I put on YouTube videos when I'm trying to fall asleep.
And last night I had on National Geographic.
Sorry.
No, not last night.
The night before last.
And it was like... What was it about?
It was about some ship that they were trying to scuba dive and find.
But I couldn't even pay attention to them the whole time.
I was like thinking in my brain.
My brain was thinking and I didn't like that.
No monkey.
As a VOD watcher from the future, I'm terribly disappointed.
But...
Yeah, so...
I had to...
I was like...
I woke up and I was like...
I didn't get like any sleep.
I fell asleep basically around like...
Around like 5 a.m.
or something.
And I was like...
I'm so...
But I woke up yesterday.
I wasn't feeling so good.
And then I felt better more towards like the later afternoon.
And so I did basically all the things that I was up...
Last night.
Or the night before.
Stressing about.
So I feel...
Much better.
Yeah.
Couldn't have watched it yesterday.
So I'm glad you changed it to today.
Oh!
Yay!
Welcome back, Nexi.
Thank you.
I'm glad...
Or rather, I'm glad that it...
Worked out.
Let's see.
So...
Cool.
You recently mentioned the planetarium cafe and the haunted airport my friend and I stumbled upon a month ago.
I saw a short film about black holes...
Wait!
I saw that one too!
It was super cool.
But all Japanese so I was just not...
Yeah!
I saw the black hole one also!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, maybe they...
I wonder how often they change it out.
Maybe per season, right?
So...
Black hole what?
It's like a...
It's like...
About...
Um...
Some Japanese researcher that...
Like...
Discovered...
Oh, what was it?
Uh...
Discovered...
Something about black holes.
I don't know.
It was...
It was like a...
Just...
I don't remember.
No.
Need more snake.
Nah, we got more snake coming.
Don't worry about it.
Discovered...
Some...
Thing.
Discovered...
Something.
Thanks for making spinal surgery with me.
Recovery more fun.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Actually...
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Get better soon.
I thought you were making that joke.
Where it's just like...
Hi, Minto.
Thank you for...
Uh...
Saving me from that car wreckage.
You...
Lifted the car with what...
You know how people make that meme?
Oh my gosh.
I thought...
I thought you were like...
Kidding about it.
Um...
Hold on.
One second.
Let me...
Uh...
Um...
One second.
My mom texted me.
Um...
She wants to make plans with me.
Plans?
Outside?
Uh...
She wants to go to like an art exhibit.
Which actually sounds kind of awesome.
So...
Not the plans.
Kind of sounds awesome.
But yeah.
So...
Last time...
We...
Um...
Uh...
Met Eva.
But then my game crashed.
So...
Um...
Yeah.
We're gonna load.
And it should be okay.
I think it's still like mid cut scene.
We just fell asleep.
Right?
And then...
And then I tried to save.
And then it was just like...
Nah.
But...
I...
I also...
One other thing.
Um...
I...
Updated the clock.
So...
Hopefully...
It's okay.
Did you give your BS?
Do a massage?
So it works better?
No.
I took out the...
Memory...
Um...
The memory card.
And I went...
All over it.
Um...
You know?
So...
Yeah.
I...
Ready to catch you live.
Also feel better soon.
Spinal surgery, bro.
I'm in bed after having my scoliosis corrected.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Everybody with their backs.
My ectoplasm is also kind of whack though.
So...
I get you.
Do you have any questions?
Do you remember the basics of CQC?
Yeah.
Blowing on it works.
Murphy.
I was kidding.
I wasn't serious.
Oh my gosh.
You would do it.
No!
I'm...
I'm smarter than that.
I know that when you blow on the...
Oh my gosh.
On the...
What's it called?
It...
On the memory cards.
It causes the moisture.
I know that.
Wisps.
Is she smart?
Chat.
Is this real?
Okay.
Let's start.
Actually, when I blow on them, I go...
That's what I do instead.
Make sure it's nice and...
Nice and...
Damp in there.
You know?
Okay.
Thank you for blowing on my memory card and recovering my PS2's memory for me that one time.
Really saved my bacon.
Nice technique.
Thank you.
That's right.
Eva.
I'm holding R1.
She's doing sussy business.
Oh!
If any children are in the chat, which I know there are, you better look away, buddy.
What's the matter?
We're surrounded.
No!
I see.
Four of them.
I don't know if that's surrounded.
R1.
You did a little peek.
We got company.
It's the ocelot unit.
Let's get out of here.
Hurry.
Don't forget your gear.
I got my gear.
Here.
Give me a hand.
I'm gonna go under the bed.
No, Eva.
You're supposed to sleep on top of the bed.
What an angle.
I know.
Eva's so hot.
This is not a basement.
This is a crawl space.
Ocelot.
He's so obsessed with me.
I think my...
What's it called, though?
My...
Don't go dying on me now.
I think all my food will be expired, though, since I changed my clock.
So, we'll see, I guess.
Did you do the thing to ocelot?
Of course.
I did a lot of stuff to ocelot.
Oh, wait.
Is this where I'm supposed to go?
Is this where I defeat them?
Oh, yeah.
This is where I have to, like, take them out, though, right?
Move.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot about this part.
Two.
Thank you.
A wooga wooga.
Respectfully.
Oh.
What are they doing?
Ah!
Move.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, let me check on my food.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Let's see if it's all rotten.
Oh!
It's okay!
It's a miracle!
All my food is good!
Wow.
It's rotten.
Wait.
How can you tell?
Oh!
Oh.
I see the flies.
Never mind.
What do I...
Oh!
I mean...
I see them now.
What about my cal...
My calorie rate's fine.
It's okay.
We'll just get more reticulated python.
You sure you want to eat that?
It says it's fairly tasty.
I mean...
What if...
Oh, my gosh.
If the...
You know...
I bet...
If...
Okay.
Imagine...
If the...
If the PS2 controller had a microphone on it.
And then you could blow the flies off.
You just go...
Can you just imagine?
Finish the podcast and did you ever make the s'mores?
No.
Five second rule.
Yeah.
So...
Oopsie.
Okay.
I'm a liar.
I accept that title.
A few fly sure.
But how does it taste?
Oh, yeah.
Right?
It's probably fine.
Okay.
What?
Not here?
Will they wake him up?
I can't remember.
Gosh.
I completely forgot about this part.
I shouldn't have gone...
Gone under the...
I shouldn't have gone under here.
I think.
Okay.
Wait a second.
Oh.
This is not a trick.
I saw the blood.
It was like...
Oh my god.
It's not a trick.
He's like quivering in his booties behind the tree.
Oh, I forgot that we lost it.
Oh, no.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
If I just keep going at it.
Yeah, he'll go to sleep eventually, so true.
Oh my gosh, okay.
How do I want to do this then?
Do you F with...
Castlevania?
Yes!
Move!
I do like, uh...
I do like Castlevania, yeah.
Should I be in my backpack?
Is that what she meant by get my stuff back?
Oh wait.
I don't think so, you guys.
I don't think so.
Where do you see the...
I am blind.
Alright.
Nighty night, fellas.
Fellers.
You guys, I'm so excited for my birthday.
But I'll be honest, okay?
I have to tell you something.
We are not celebrating my birthday on my birthday.
I...
I'm celebrating it the day after.
Oh my god, his poor leg!
Did you see it shaking?
Baby.
Move!
Hmm...
So...
Yeah, I'm sorry that it'll be a little bit late.
But...
His leg is so sad.
What's wrong?
Okay.
Time to what's wrong him.
Oh wait.
Because he's down, you're not gonna mess with him, is he?
Move!
Sorry, I completely forgot about this part, guys.
So just give me a second to get all...
reoriented and everything.
What's wrong?
Um...
He'll be woken up?
I don't think so.
Unless they run over to him.
Where's the other guy that's...
Oh, here.
Okay, hold on.
I don't think he's gonna get woken up.
I think we're fine.
Now can I get this guy?
I hear them all running around...
Yeah, they don't wake up in this.
Yeah, that's why it says enemy 7.
Because we took them out.
Move!
And then I'll get to the...
I'll go to the...
rooftop.
Move!
Stop telling me what to do!
Wait, isn't there a guy...
on the rooftop?
Let me think about it.
Oh my gosh, don't see me.
Don't see me.
I'm gonna crawl over.
I'll grab him though.
I'll CQC him.
Oh.
Gosh, he spooked me.
The camo index?
It's okay.
You weren't supposed to...
Hold on, wait.
You weren't supposed to turn around, you asshole!
Oh my god.
Don't stab me!
Oh!
I can't.
Take him down!
Yeah!
Okay, they don't notice me anymore.
We're fine.
Oh, they do, I think.
Up there!
Where is it?
You can't even get me!
Dummies.
They're so stupid.
Anyway.
We're fine, everybody.
All we have is a severe burn.
Don't worry about it.
The guy turned around!
I was going to...
I was going to shoot him, but...
It's just...
It is what it is.
Ointment for the burn.
And then we bandage the burn.
It's like we were...
Never hurt.
Ever.
It was a bit slow.
It's a bit of a slow...
Weekend for me.
Thank you!
It's like we were never ever burned.
I can get a cold in this game.
And actually...
I don't think I've ever seen that.
There he goes.
Why is it so silent?
Why is he naked?
Okay.
That's it.
Highly recommend playing Splinter Cell.
I don't know.
I...
I'm obviously not against Splinter Cell.
It's just rather...
Oh my gosh.
Don't run!
Oh.
I have to find all the guys.
This is like a little hide and seek mission.
Okay.
I can get this guy.
They're not going to wake him up though.
Shoot.
I don't know.
Surely he couldn't still be on the...
On the...
On the ceiling.
That'd be nutso.
That would be absolute craziness.
If he just stayed up there the whole time.
No guy would ever do that.
Where'd they go?
Actually.
Oh
my gosh.
My aim.
It's fine if I just even get them once.
Oh.
Hello?
There we go.
They don't care.
Why?
What do you mean?
Shoot.
Uh oh.
That was too obvious.
I was just standing.
No.
Up where?
She's under there.
You guys.
They're just like a little blind.
I wish that guy would come back though.
Hey.
Come back.
I have three left.
Hmm.
The one guy.
Where's the other two?
I were.
A little ocelot soldier.
Where would I be?
Underwear.
Oh no.
I made you say underwear.
Isn't that so embarrassing for you?
Try meowing at them.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
No.
Don't move.
You jerks.
I was so close.
Move.
No.
I should just have my gun out.
You.
You son of a...
Thank you.
Yeah.
That's a burn wound.
Remove all your clothing.
Slowly to not damage the wound.
Move.
All right.
Come back.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm just gonna go take care of them.
You guys.
I'm bored.
I'm bored of being up here.
If I just like...
Take them down.
If I just run.
Should be fine.
There's three of them.
But I only see...
How the...
Oh.
My camo.
That's why.
Go snake.
Go upstairs.
Snake.
I'm scared.
Move.
Couldn't possibly be my ammo.
Okay guys.
But...
I don't know.
Where did he go?
Yeah.
That's right.
They're all going down.
One by...
Where's he hiding?
One by one.
Did I get him at all?
I don't even know if I did.
Pretty fast.
Can see why you love stealth games.
Aim.
Don't go.
Hey.
It's a controller.
Okay?
Controller is so hard to aim.
Can you blame me?
Where's the last guy though?
I don't think I got him.
I
don't think I got him.
Controller being blamed.
VTuber.
How dare you blame the controller.
When it's literally...
You using the controller.
VTuber.
That's like so embarrassing VTuber.
Tiger stripe.
Going with the T.
You should game over again so we can see that cutscene again.
Wait.
Oh.
There is no way in here.
No matter where to stay in my birthday.
Kiki.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Where are they?
I think I hear them in there.
Happy birthday dear Kiki Kitty.
Happy birthday to you.
Punch him.
Where's the other guy now?
We have one guy snoozing on the job.
Hey Snoozer.
Where are you at?
I feel like he'd be up there.
I can't remember.
To the right of me in the grass?
Like over this way?
Wait, hold on.
I have... oh, wrong button.
I have...
Emotion D.
He's over there.
In the grass.
First time I played was to kill all the enemy soldiers with the neck cut.
Oh my gosh!
You're so brutal!
Yes?
Yeah, just your imagination, idiot.
It's Quincy.
Yes?
Awww.
They got stuff?
Wow!
Sea Med.
Time to loot!
Time to loot our little friends.
Oh my gosh, keep pressing the wrong thing.
Sea Med.
Suture kit!
Nice.
I'll take it.
What you got?
You got... oh, nice.
I'll take it, I'll take it, I'll take it, I'll take it.
What you got?
Corn meds.
Oh my gosh, a ration!
In another game?
In another life?
I would have been like...
Suppressor!
Everybody who was just like, rip suppressor.
We no longer have to say...
That...
Wait, didn't I get this guy earlier?
What about you?
I'm so sorry I shot you in the leg.
There's his blood on the ground!
Oh...
Oh yeah, thank you.
There's the stuff on top of the box.
Ow!
Get
ready!
Who is it?
Huh?
I've been waiting for this moment.
Oh my god, it's coming.
Oh god.
Hold on, I'm not...
I wasn't ready, my heart!
That's the stance.
I don't think so.
What?
A female spy?
This bitch is wearing perfume.
Oh my god!
Stay where you are.
I've had enough of your judo.
My judo.
I see you've got yourself a single action army.
That's right.
There'll be no accidents this time.
He took his advice.
Look at his back!
What did you say?
It's a nice gun, I'll give you that.
But the engraving gives you no tactical advantage whatsoever.
Unless you were planning to auction it off as a collector's item.
And you're forgetting one more very big thing.
The engraving.
You don't have what it takes to kill me.
We'll see.
Dummy!
Oh god, it's that!
Yeah!
Look at the tire marks on his face.
Baby!
Six shots.
That thing only carries six shots.
The Makarov carries eight.
You have to get a feel for how many you have left.
I can't.
This is a high-clutch weapon.
It's not meant for shooting people.
Damn!
You're so stupid!
What?
The fact that he gets so pissy.
This isn't over yet.
He gets so pissy.
But listens to him.
Don't.
Why?
He's still young.
Run away, little guy.
Little monkey.
Damn it.
I've got to get back before he does.
Go, go, go.
Oh, Eva.
What a woman.
Oh my god, she's crazy.
How much air is she getting?
Oh my god!
Damn, Eva.
The thing is, killing Ocelot...
Sorry, I was holding R1.
Killing Ocelot...
You solve so many of the game's problems.
But that's actually not even the case.
Ocelot's not our guy, you know?
She remembers the basics of CQM.
Close corners motorcycle.
Big Boss's best attribute was to be able to roast enemy soldiers until they loved him.
I know!
Everybody loves the legend!
He nicked the enemy until they wanted his approval.
Like pick-up artists.
But he has the charisma, you know?
Unlike those pick-up artist guys.
Snake actually has the charisma.
Don't forget to breathe!
I literally had to bite my fingers to stop myself from continuing.
CBox!
Big Riz.
Was that everything?
Is there anything else?
Oh no!
Wait, I didn't get to finish mugging my guys!
Aww man.
Zombie!
NGS3 is just Ocelot's retelling of events.
Which is why everyone, especially Snake, is so cool.
Uh...
Oh.
Let's also get some... let's dispose of our food.
Dispose of our...
I don't wanna get... I don't wanna... I don't wanna get sick.
I don't wanna get sick.
Okay.
Unless... any snakes?
Yep.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I'm so stupid.
There we go.
Yay!
Anything in here?
Nada.
Nada thing.
Ever play the 3DS version?
I've played it before.
It's just...
Really... besides crouch walking...
It's...
I...
I honestly am just like...
How can you play this type of game on such a small screen?
You know?
Still in a nightmare.
Snake feeder.
I didn't see any mushrooms or anything.
So I guess we'll...
Let me check...
Okay.
Please.
I'm trying to triangle over...
Okay.
I'll just go in.
Let me check in here.
Real quick.
I think...
Oh!
Wait!
You guys, we can do it ourselves!
What the hell is this?
We can recreate the moment!
3DS controls are fine to me.
I mean, if that's your opinion, that's totally fine.
It's harder for me.
Oki...
Bug juice.
Doki.
Let's go.
I don't get the reference.
Um...
Watch...
Me play...
Metal Gear Solid 3 Pachi slot machine.
Oh...
Swamps.
Oh, let's codex some people first.
A little bit.
It looks like you've got rid of all the Ocelots.
I did.
Yeah.
Now proceed with the rescue of Sokolov.
According to Eva, you should start by going to the crevice to the north and...
Can we trust her?
What's that?
Eva's with the KGB, isn't she?
Can I really believe what she says?
How do I know she won't double-cross me?
There are no guarantees in espionage, Snake.
Only calculated guesses.
At this point in time, the KGB stands nothing to gain by stabbing us in the back.
We're missing a lot of calculations then, I think.
So you're saying I can trust her?
I'm saying the chance that she'll betray you is low.
Don't worry, Kev.
I didn't know about the trinket, Snake.
Of course, we checked the route she gave you against our own data.
It looks like a pretty solid infiltration route.
It makes good use of weak spots in the enemy's defenses.
You shouldn't have any problems.
Follow the route Eva showed you and proceed with the mission.
Roger.
If you're not a controller gamer, it's super bad.
First, enter the cave through the crevice.
See?
It leads to the north.
So head that way.
Who would you pick actor-wise for your top five favorite characters?
Actor-wise?
Like voice actor?
I see you have a calorie mate.
Calorie mate?
The thing you're holding now?
Yeah.
Oh.
The little block that looks like a cookie?
It looks like a cookie.
Try it.
It's pretty good.
Okay.
But what is this thing?
I've never seen anything like it.
It's space food.
Calorie mate is an energy supplement.
It contains all the proteins, lipids, vitamins, carbohydrates, and minerals needed for a balanced diet.
It's a well-balanced food.
Hashtag not sponsored.
Because of that, it's just perfect for giving your body the nutrition it needs in combat.
It sounds like a space-age food.
It is space food.
Real astronaut food is not very good, but that should taste fine.
Yeah.
And it'll help balance out all this jungle food I'm eating.
Liquid calorie mate.
It's easy and quick to eat, so it's perfect when you're running late for an important mission in the morning.
Hashtag not sponsored.
I've never been late for a mission.
Really?
Aren't you always keeping people waiting?
Actually, I guess here...
It's easy to keep track of your calorie intake...
I guess maybe this is technically sponsored.
... and receiving efficient body needs, so it's good for losing weight, too.
All of the geisha girls in Japan use it for watching their calories.
Ooh, wow.
Is that why they're all so slim?
Right.
And any diet where you eat nothing at all is bad for the body.
Sasuka, paramedic weeb.
I see.
Talking about the geisha girls.
You seem to know a lot about Japan, don't you?
Yes.
I love Japan.
Sorry.
The way she says it.
Yes.
I love Japan.
Weeb.
Oh my gosh.
Weeaboo.
Get out of here.
Yes.
I see you've got yourself a ration.
I love Japan.
Rations are portable meals carried by Soviet soldiers.
I've heard some nasty stories about how they taste.
Me, too.
I want to try an MRE stream.
Great.
I think I'll...
I'm worried I might throw up.
You should be grateful.
Those things are designed to last.
No matter how hard you try, they will not last.
No matter how long you keep a ration, it'll never go bad.
Yes.
I love Japan.
And they're surprisingly good for you, too.
I'd take a snake over this any day.
Even if it's a little rotten.
How about rotten by like a whole... a whole... when was it?
A whole two decades.
Which snake has the best default outfit?
For me, it's Venom.
I'm a sucker for that poncho thing.
Oh, I do love the poncho.
Best default outfit, though, I'd say is MGS2.
Yeah.
I love that.
Favorite actors, though.
Mam, mam, mam, mam.
Otacon...
I think Otacon is at the top, for me.
There's also...
He's like in a lot of games, too.
I love, also...
What's his name?
Josh Keaton.
Yang Ocelot, maybe, too, for me.
Of course, David.
David Hayter, I'm not even gonna include because I think that's too easy.
Yes.
I think that's like ultimate number one.
That's like number zero.
Kiefer?
I feel like Snake spends so much of his game out of his element.
But whenever Ocelot shows up, Snake becomes the biggest bad.
I know!
He does!
Oh, Cam Clark!
Yes!
Oh my gosh, Cam Clark is awesome.
Cam Clark actually put him number one.
And then Ocelot, and then Otacon, and then young Ocelot.
You want to save?
Yeah.
And I'm gonna make a different save.
New file!
Let's see how the date does.
If it changes.
Let's see.
Oh!
Wow!
So young, so fresh!
I don't know why these codex are so...
The audio is so low.
...
They're quite realistic.
I've got all the real I can handle here in the jungle.
Is the front part of your skirt connected to the mid part?
Or are they separate?
No, you don't get it.
Precisely because it's realistic.
Dolphy dream!
With the images jumping out of the screen at you.
Those are really expensive, though.
It makes for a nice escape from reality.
I have to admit, it made my eyes tired.
But it was really intense.
Oh.
It's separate.
Technically.
Unfortunately, they don't make very many of those movies anymore.
But if it's easier to make it connected, don't worry about it.
When did it come out?
Babycore, thanks for the 5k food!
I was still in college, so probably about ten years ago?
Guess I'm out of luck then.
You know, they're coming out with household versions of video cassette recorders.
Video cassette recorders?
One day you'll be able to see old movies anytime you want.
No way.
It'll be like having a movie theater in your own home.
Really?
It's like if you had a record of a movie film etched onto it instead of music.
It'll work the same way.
Paramedic, you're a genius.
No, really.
And someday they might make movies where you control the characters yourself.
What?
Sounds like magic.
It'll happen.
Make sure you stay alive to see it, Snake.
This lot plays a minor role in all that happens in MGS.
Huey is the hub by which the entire plot turns.
He's also the chur- Okay.
Bait used to be believable, you guys.
Hey, Snake.
Remember back at the abandoned factory when you whittled the grip of that 45 down?
Yeah?
I've never heard of a customization like that before.
Why the grip?
Ooh...
To fit it with a knife.
A knife?
What do you got there, Snake?
A knife!
Ow!
I'll turn it up a little bit.
Badass.
CQC!
CQC baby, CQC!
Oh wait, hold on.
Let's uh...
After this one, I'll go into the box and call him.
But he might have something to say about the AK first.
Such a funny looking gun.
It's so thin at the top.
Like it just looks strange.
Huh.
Why would she have so much stuff?
It does.
Yeah, she must get around, huh?
Yeah.
She travels all over probably.
Oh dang it, I did it again.
There we go.
Let's see.
Cardboard box.
I never use the anti-personnel sensor, I'll be honest.
So I'm just gonna unequip it.
Ugh!
Ow!
Box!
Yippee!
What would a box be doing in the jungle?
That makes no sense.
Oh my god.
He has so much to say.
We haven't talked to Sigint in a while.
Hahaha.
I did it again.
This is how like Bigfoot legends are-are created.
Someone sees a cardboard box running around in the jungle.
They'd say it's like, Bigfoot.
Except it's here, O'Brien.
Hahaha.
Uh huh.
I'm not a big fan of the bigfoot.
I've never played with that.
Mm-hmm.
She's kind of crazy.
She matches my freak.
Ooh.
Nice.
No safety!
Yeah.
The release lever's been taken off as well, meaning the hammer won't fall, even with the safety on.
So I can just cock and lock.
That, and you get the added bonus of not having any mechanical noise from de-cocking, even with the safety on.
The perfect pistol for a sneaking mission, huh?
Snake's about to cock and lock.
Let's go, baby!
Let's go!
Uh, Snake?
What are you doing?
I'm in a box.
I'm in a box!
A cardboard box?
Why are you in it?
It's his destiny to be in the box!
I was just looking at it, and suddenly I got this irresistible urge to get inside.
Yeah.
No.
Not just an urge.
More than that.
It was my destiny to be here.
In the box.
Destiny?
Yeah.
And then, when I put it on, I suddenly got this feeling of inner peace.
I can't put it into words.
Such a cat boy.
Safe.
Like this is where I was meant to be.
Like I'd found the key to true happiness.
Does any of that make sense?
Not even a little.
You should come inside the box.
Then you'll know what I mean.
Man, I don't want to know what you mean!
Between you and Paramedic, is everyone but me that is hooked up with a major strain?
Yeah, well.
Anyway, I suppose even that dumbass box might make a decent disguise if you wear it inside a building.
Oh, everybody's strange!
Everybody's strange!
Love it.
What a cat.
What a cat guy.
It's my destiny to watch him in.
It's my calling.
Where is it?
Stop.
Nice.
Any Gators afoot?
Oh!
What's a Gator?
What's a log?
Log or Gator?
Put in your votes right now.
Oh!
I thought it was a log!
Oh my gosh.
I thought it was a log.
But it was a gator.
Guys, I'm gonna ask you to backseat.
Because I don't remember where the craw cat is.
So, if you would...
Once we get there...
I vaguely remember having to go up a tree and it being on a branch or something.
On the left?
Look at this guy!
Look at him!
Oh!
There's so much stuff down there!
How do I...
I'm gonna take off the suppressor.
I don't think we need it here, right?
I don't remember there being any guys.
Yeah, goodnight!
Don't mind me.
I'm just grabbing this stuff.
Oh no!
I got kissed!
The kiss of death!
Oh my gosh, I got kissed!
I got kissed!
I also want this frog.
Come here, frog.
Come here.
Frog!
That guy's gonna wake up.
Oh wait, I didn't get this one.
Oh, just kidding.
That's why I didn't get this one.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Oh, do I have to go under cure?
A leech!
Blood-sucking leeches attached to the body.
Stamina will continually decrease while leeches are attached.
Burn them off with a lit cigar.
Goodbye, leech.
Oh, leech.
Aw, leech.
Wait, suddenly, for some reason, I don't want leech to go.
How peculiar.
Alright, let's watch out for any gators.
It's kinda hard to see them, isn't it?
Can I see them with the thermal goggles?
Yes, but...
Why?
I'm also gonna take out my gun.
Hug the left.
Swim under the log.
This is where I need to go though, isn't it?
Like, actually?
Isn't this just where I need to...
How do I swim again?
Oh no, I'm hungry!
Oh gosh.
Under the log to the left if you want the craw cat.
But isn't this also just where I need to go?
Ow!
Oh, I got a grenade.
That's cool.
Is there any fish here?
Oh, there's other stuff.
Okay, I get it, I get it, I get it.
Maybe the method is a little unconventional, but whatever works, works.
Dead.
I'm not on the nipple!
Snake!
I was breastfeeding!
Okay.
I think here...
I should be...
I should be naked.
Yes.
No uniform worn on the upper body does not provide much camouflage.
Hold on.
Do your thing, Snake.
Please.
Paramedic with... with a leech.
Okay.
I don't remember that one.
With the leech.
Spin around.
What?
You want me to make him throw up?
It's fine.
Alright.
Okay, so I climb up... ah!
I climb up here.
Eva!
Nice.
What does that mean?
Boss.
Why are you naked?
I don't know.
So I can see the leech is better.
Oh.
The fact that she thought it was about her.
She was like, huh?
Wait, huh?
Mm-hmm.
Try me.
She played Outer Wilds.
Not the actual universe.
The universe as the intelligence community sees it.
I realized that the gravity in this universe was holding me back.
Is that all?
People and countries are both changed by their environment.
And by the times.
You and me both.
That sounds like what the boss was saying.
There's a world of difference between this country and America.
But it's only a difference of position.
A difference of perspective.
Mm.
Coming here made me realize something.
Half of what I'd been told was a complete and utter lie.
The other half was a conveniently constructed lie.
Mm.
Where's the truth then?
It's hidden in the lies.
In the lies.
Are you lying too?
Who knows?
I've been trained to make even the most severe falsehood sound like the honest truth.
Is she going to tell me to try that in a small town?
Aren't you?
No.
I believe because I have to.
Even if it is a lie.
She believed.
She lied.
I'll have to remember that.
Spieve!
If you need me, give me a call on the radio.
My frequency is 142.52.
See ya.
142.52.
Let's dig in, guys.
What do we want to eat?
We want a reticulated python?
Do we want to try the calorie mate?
I feel like we should save this for like a... for like a fun moment, right?
When I need it.
Actually, guys, I have to go to the bathroom real quick.
Is that okay?
Is it okay if I run to the little ghosty's room?
Can't spell Spieve without Eve.
Oh my gosh.
You're so right.
But before... Here, I'll leave you guys with your own snack.
Here's your own snack.
You're welcome.
Here, I'll be right back.
I'll be fast.
Mint, be fast.
Mint, be quick.
I'm still in a dream.
I've gone fishing.
Okay.
B or B.
I'm back.
Did you wash your hands?
No, I just use my sleeves.
Okay.
Cool, let's go up this tree.
Oh, my food, I'm hungry.
Why did you admit that?
I'm going to eat the python.
Oh my gosh.
He's such a monster.
Look at this guy.
Oh, nasty!
Snake!
Why are you going with such like...
Are you gonna eat it or are you gonna spit everything out?
Snake eater!
Oh, he likes it though.
That's tasty everybody.
Oh, that's right.
It's right...
There, isn't it?
That's it?
Okay.
Here we go.
That's tasty.
Okay.
Careful now.
Maybe I should kill these crocs down there.
So that...
If I fall, I don't die.
You know what I mean?
Maybe I should take them out.
Then I can get some good food.
Right?
Never thought that snake eater was literal.
Oh yeah, it is.
Just don't fall.
Oh, I'm still gone fishing.
Thank you.
Sorry.
I realized also...
I was just like, wait a second.
My food would have been spoiled anyway.
Even if I hadn't changed my clock.
Because I hadn't played in a week.
I do kind of want the food though.
I want the gator.
Leave the crocs.
They did nothing wrong.
You guys!
Just don't fall.
Yeah, food is based on real time.
I was so close.
Okay.
The food.
Oh, but I'd have to swim all the way back.
Okay.
Alright.
If I do this, do I go into hang mode?
Snake, turn around.
Snake, climb up.
Use your arm.
Snake.
Snake, climb up.
Snake, your leg!
What did you do?
A broken bone!
Oh my gosh, we have to do surgery.
What do I do for a broken bone?
A splint?
And a bandage.
All better.
No more broken bone.
Well guys, I wanted a snack, so...
You think he's...
The fact that he doesn't come after me is kind of crazy.
There we go.
Snake, just do it.
Just go.
Yeah!
Nice!
Okay, is it this side?
Just around here?
Just around...
The river... Oh, I got kissed.
Yeah.
Rip suppressor is fine.
I don't really...
Shoot with it much.
Goodbye!
Thanks for the gift.
Okay, Snake, you ready?
Uh...
Let's try this again.
Oh!
Here.
Paramedic.
I forgot.
Here.
I'll get... I'll get another one.
Oh look, there's a fish here.
This is good.
Wait, why can't I use my knife?
Oh, see, see, see.
I got it.
I wanna... Why can't I use my knife?
Why can't I use my knife on the fish?
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Oh, he's at my feet.
Yay.
Gone fishing.
Yeah, now for real.
Paramedic, I have leeches!
Oh my god, my...
Not there.
Then where?
See the leeches?
Leeches?
Bitches?
Yeah, you've got leeches all over you.
Leeches will sometimes attach themselves to you if you spend a long time in the water or the swamp.
When you've got leeches on you, they'll suck your blood, causing you to lose stamina.
You should get rid of them as soon as possible.
No!
To get rid of leeches, go into Cure in the Survival Viewer and press your cigar into them.
Or, if you use the insecticidal bug juice ahead of time, the leeches won't bother you as long as the bug juice is in effect.
I don't mind the leeches.
I don't really mind them.
They don't do much.
They're just sucking a little bit of blood.
Is blood that important to humans?
I don't even know.
It's like not that even big of a deal.
We're totally fine.
We're like so fine.
It's like whatever.
Just a little bit of leech.
What?
You could even see it on him!
That was crazy.
It's also crazy that they get...
They go through my pants.
How do they... how large is their teeth?
Alright.
I'm already hungry!
No, I gotta get this hat.
Please.
This is really important.
Okay.
I think I...
Shut up, snake.
You can train grip here too?
Wait, there's a train grip in this game too?
I tried...
Okay, wait.
To... hang on it.
I tried pressing X.
I think that was the wrong thing.
Is it triangle?
Oh.
My bad.
I pressed the wrong thing, you guys.
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh, I should have eaten first.
I get it now.
I get why you guys said that.
But it's okay.
We got this.
It'll last.
We're fine.
Don't know what to write.
Thank you.
Yippee!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
We got the best thing in the game, baby!
Gonna eat some...
Oh, wait.
Let's ask about our...
Let's ask about our crocs.
What if paramedic says, what are those?
I see you've captured an Indian gavial.
I did.
The Indian gavial is a crocodile that originally lived in freshwater regions in India and Nepal.
Why are Indian crocodiles way out here?
Good question.
They're captive crocodiles that were brought here for research purposes.
But escaped and became wild again.
Oh.
Indian gavials are large creatures.
Adult males grow to over six meters in length.
You'll never catch one alive.
Even if you use the tranquilizer gun.
Got it.
So...
You'll never catch me alive.
And I took that literally.
Yes, I did look into that.
You know what they always say.
Tastes like chicken.
Sounds delicious.
But be careful when capturing an Indian gavial.
Normally, they're cowardly creatures.
But the ones in the wild are not.
The ones in the forest there are belligerent.
Apparently, they attack humans.
What do you mean?
They weren't the direct subject of any serious research.
But some think they may have become violent as a side effect of the atomic research that was conducted nearby.
Aww.
I'm so sad.
Thanks for the super chat!
Where is he storing that?
In his pants.
Probably.
Maybe that's why everyone becomes in love with the legend.
They're just like, wow.
He's a legend.
He's packing.
Little did they know, it's just the croc hat.
They're like, oh my god.
How do I put it on again?
Is it an item?
Yes.
We must get rid of...
We'll get rid of the...
Never mind.
I can't get rid of the revival pill.
We'll get rid of the fake death pill and replace it with the croc hat.
Yay!
I'm one of you now!
Oh my gosh.
Yay!
Also, let's eat it.
Oh, I forgot to eat it.
Eat!
Really?
The python is better than the crocodile?
That's crazy.
Arowana.
I don't wanna.
But you arowana...
Oh my god.
It's still alive.
Oh my god, sushi.
This, like, mukbang footage is just too much for me.
The sounds are...
That's it?
That's all you're gonna have?
Wow.
Hmm...
Yeah.
Pretty tasty.
Ha ha ha!
He left so much of it though!
Oh my gosh...
The back of the craw cat...
I've never thought about how the craw cat is...
Also, his hair goes through it.
Have you noticed that?
Oh wait, maybe it's his bandana.
But the back of the craw cat is just very...
very cursed.
Oh yeah, let's call everybody.
Look at my hat!
Nice crack!
Crocodiles taste apparently very gamey.
Ahhh.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
Yeah, I can go really fast.
Yeah.
Oh, I forgot about the action button.
Major Zero?
Snake, you'll be helpless if a crocodile attacks you in the water.
You can't see behind you when you're swimming.
So, if you're in a crocodile-infested swamp, keep an eye on your six.
My six.
Also, by using your sensors, you should be able to detect crocodiles before they get too close.
Hmmm.
Okay.
Snake, what in God's name...
How does it look?
I know.
It looks cool.
Yeah?
It looks cool on you.
I know.
It does?
Yeah.
I don't think cool is the right word.
Well, what would you say then?
Why?
What's wrong with it?
Yeah.
What's wrong...
Don't you think it looks silly?
Doesn't it make you laugh?
Aren't you going to ask me what the hell I was thinking?
No.
Snake is trying to be a little clown over here.
I think it really does look good.
It reminds me of The Alligator People.
Oh, the...
What?
The Alligator People.
It's a science fiction movie.
You've never heard of it?
No.
I'm laughing.
Well, you should see it sometime.
Everybody should laugh.
Make you feel good.
It's about this guy who gets hurt in a car accident and tries to heal his wound.
Snake would literally be that person that's like the class clown in class.
But then his head turns into a crocodile head.
You look just like him with the mask on.
Does something stupid hoping people will laugh.
That's awesome.
Right.
Huh?
Oh, never mind.
I suppose you might be able to disguise yourself as a crocodile by wearing that cap and sticking your head out of the water.
Yeah.
Love the gif of Snake eating it on Discord of it.
Yeah, sped up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I really like Paramedic.
She's so cool.
Yeah.
Yeah, she is.
Sigint, what do you think of my hat?
Hey, you got an M1911A1.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
A 45.
50 years since the army adopted the first model and they're still using them.
It's a real gem of an automatic pistol.
Sigint.
But aren't you going to need more than just one little handgun?
Not at all.
When you're in a tight spot or fighting in close quarters, sometimes a handgun works better than a rifle.
And if I equip a knife at the same time, I can instantaneously switch.
Switch over to hand-to-hand combat.
I see.
That 45 you've got there is a lot different from the original, though.
How so?
Looks like someone did some serious work on it.
It's more than a little.
First of all, the feeding ramp is polished to a mirror sheen.
It's not going to have any feeding problems.
The slide's been replaced with a reinforced version and it meshes perfectly with the frame.
He's geeking out, you guys.
The frame itself has been iron welded and scraped down multiple times for maximum precision.
Yeah.
The front strap part of the frame has been checkered to make it dig into the hand.
That prevents any slipping.
The sight system's original, too.
It's a three-dot type.
It's got an enlarged front sight, giving it superior target sighting capability.
The regular hammer's been replaced with a ring hammer.
That enhances the cocking control and increases the hammer down speed.
They also reworked the grip safety to accommodate the ring hammer.
Wow.
Looks like they eliminated it altogether.
Why do we need SIGINT if Snake is like this?
The thumb safety and the slide stop are extended to allow for more precise handling.
SIGINT's over here taking notes.
He's like, oh.
So you can use a high grip.
And the trigger itself is a long type for easy finger access.
The trigger pull is about 3.5 pounds.
That's about a pound and a half lighter than normal.
The magazine well...
Oh my god, he's still going.
...put in a new magazine.
The magazine catch button has been cut down low to make it harder to hit it by mistake.
The mainspring housing has been changed to a flat type to increase grip.
When did you have time to look at all of this?
...so it doesn't slip and recoil when firing.
On top of that, they added cocking serrations to the front part of the slide.
Oh, 18 out of 18.
I think we're good.
That lets you load and eject cartridges faster in an emergency.
Whoever did this is a professional.
No question, this thing could shoot a one-hole at 25 yards in a machine rest.
Well, I'll be damned.
That's some gun.
Yeah.
I've never used a weapon this fine in my life.
This fine.
Wow.
Oh my god.
A cap shaped like a crocodile head, you say?
Yeah.
What do you think?
I think it's a great idea.
Yeah.
You know, animal disguises are one of the oldest tricks in the book in the intelligence world.
I don't know whether it's true or not, but I've heard that during World War II, the OSS used to use cow suits.
Cow suits?
Supposedly, they sent agents out to hide in herds of real cows so they could spy on enemy units as they passed by.
Giving up books worth of gun facts.
Nowadays, I guess most people wouldn't even give a crocodile shaped cap a second look.
They'd think it was just a gag item.
But if you use it the right way, it can be an effective weapon for spying.
Spying?
I gotta hand it to you, Snake.
You're one sharp guy.
You okay, Snake?
Forget it.
Huh?
All he wanted is a laugh, you guys.
All he wanted was a laugh.
Not even just a little chortle, a chuckle, anything.
No one gives him a single little...
Oh my gosh.
So funny.
Fish.
Okay.
I wanna get those down there, obviously.
Is there anything?
I mean, I'm sure there's stuff.
Wait, that's where we...
Okay, wait.
Where is...
We came from over there.
Can I get up on that land over there?
I can't remember.
Let's try.
Stun gun.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Oh, I got kissed.
You won't fool me.
Probably.
It's our mushroom.
That area is known as Chorni Prud.
The name means something like the black shore in Russian.
Chorni Prud.
It got its name from the deep swamp that covers the area.
The crocodiles in that swamp are extremely vicious.
Vicious.
Apparently, they've already chewed up a bunch of soldiers out on patrol.
What?
Now, no one even dares to go near the swamp.
They said that most of the soldiers who were killed were attacked from behind while they were in the water.
You be careful out there.
I'm okay.
What kind of unit are those ocelots I fought a little while ago?
The ocelot unit is an elite group...
Is she allowed to talk to us?
Like...
Are they just not paying attention to her?
The special forces wing of Gru.
They've undergone even more rigorous training than regular.
Their skill with weapons is the stuff of legends.
You'll find they're much better shots than the rest of Gru.
Watch yourself.
The crevice that leads to the cave is still a ways to the north.
Keep heading that way.
Okay.
But like...
There's a trap here.
She's on the toilet.
Obviously.
Why is it so hard sometimes?
You almost got me.
Hey man.
I'm in no trouble.
I can crawl underneath it.
Probably.
My craw cat though.
Don't get in the way, craw cat.
Craw cat.
It's bouncing.
Oh, I have the leech on.
Where is it?
Oh!
I don't see it.
Wait.
I don't see a leech.
Do you guys see a leech?
Oh, sorry.
Do you guys...
Ew!
Gross!
It's like a little tongue sticking out of my body.
Eww.
Okay, bye.
Do you guys think I'll make it?
Oh my God.
The craw...
We're playing...
We're playing limbo with the craw cat.
Oh my God.
It's like resting right on him.
Ah!
Yeah!
Oh my God, we made it.
Eva!
Was that you?
Oh my god.
Thanks,
Eva.
Thanks a lot.
Eh, we'll leave it.
Oh, hold on.
I want to ask about the mushrooms.
Sorry.
So many...
So many codex.
Arowana.
I don't wanna.
Wow.
Does that mean they're, like, endangered?
I think I remember the arowana from Animal Crossing.
And the knifefish.
The coelacanth!
Almost all organisms on Earth have evolved in various shapes and forms.
But these fish have kept the same form for hundreds of millions of years.
Baffling, isn't it?
Wow.
Sure.
Perfect form.
Well, I can see you're not interested.
How does it taste?
Not at all.
I love ancient fish.
Why?
They taste pretty good.
Oh, specifically the ancient ones, you guys.
The ancient...
Yeah, it's peak fish form.
They don't need to change.
Don't fix what's not broken, you know?
Coral snakes?
I don't even see one.
Since leeches feed off their hosts, do you think when snake eats, they both go yummy?
Yummers?
That's taste.
Mmm.
Red and yellow.
Kill a fellow.
Red and black.
Friend of Jack.
It tellementally destroys them from attacking.
There are many animals that mimic the colors of known poisonous animals as a defense.
See, by mimicking other poisonous creatures, they increase their chances of survival.
There is another non-poisonous snake called the milk snake that borrows its coloring from the coral snake.
Yeah.
That's the one that's red and black.
You're not even listening, are you?
No.
If red touches yellow, you're a dead fellow.
Red and black?
You're okay, Jack?
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes.
It says here that coral snakes are horrible at destroying their Queen.
So yeah,
if you ever see those, if the red... and you could tell in the picture too that it was red, yellow, red, yellow, black, red, yellow, black, yellow, red, yellow, black, yellow.
But if it's red, black, yellow, black, red, black, yellow, black, then it's safe.
And that's a rock fact.
We don't go outside, Minto.
That's so true.
You know what?
That's fine.
I'm just saying if you go outside...
Oh, this is the dogs.
Oh no!
The dogs!
Okay, let's put my shirt back on.
What does mint on white mean?
Um...
It means it's too late.
What's the dog doing?
I don't want the dog to be doing nothing.
I don't want to fight the dog.
Don't get hit.
I'm trying to find that fence though, right?
I think.
I'm trying not to... I'm looking around for any traps.
Or wait, is this the... this is the dog area, isn't it?
Or am I crazy?
Oh, my silencers!
Oh my gosh, you're so right.
Um, actually, they're not silencers, they're suppressors.
Because I don't technically silence...
Um, your gun.
They only suppress...
AH!
Control here.
We have evidence of an enemy intruder.
Commence alert formation.
Acknowledged.
Sending reinforcements.
Use extra caution.
I didn't see it.
I didn't see the rope.
Was there a rope there?
I didn't... I didn't see the rope.
Snake, at this rate, we're gonna...
We're gonna run out of stuff.
Look at the dog!
I see him over there.
They're not gonna come in through here, do they?
They shouldn't, because this is all, you know...
Oh, question.
Can I crawl over the mines like I used to?
You know, like how...
Look at the dog.
Yeah.
Okay, I couldn't remember if I could or not.
It's like all games except 5, right?
That I could do that?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, god!
What are you running around here for?
Willy nil- AH!
There's a mine there?
I am stealthy.
Stealthy.
Except that I ran over a mine, but that's okay.
I'm like 85% stealth.
They'll leave.
Let's keep going.
They won't notice me.
Maybe.
There's one right there too!
Rude!
I don't want them to notice me moving around, you know?
But we do gotta take out that dog.
Sorry, dog.
Oh, he's gonna go to sleep.
If it bites you and you die, it's venomous.
If it bites you and you die, it's poisonous.
Oh, wait!
Sorry.
If you bite it and you die, it's poisonous.
Paramedic called the coral snake poisonous.
Oh!
Paramedic!
You need to go back to med school!
Get called out by my chat!
Hi!
Get called out, paramedic!
You need to go back to school, snake.
Can you...
The dog just jumped over that?
I think the dog just jumped over that tree?
That log?
Oh!
What?
How did you hear that?
What do you mean, huh?
Was it the dog going, He was barking at a squirrel or something!
It's the...
It's the jungle!
There's so much stuff in here!
What are you talking about?
Huh?
You guys, I don't trust myself anymore.
So I'm gonna just crawl.
I don't trust...
There's like one right by the tree, I remember.
I don't trust myself anymore.
Just the wind.
Isn't there one?
Yeah, it's right there.
Some days they bark at a tree frog.
Oh my god.
When did you get here?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
What the?
Oh, there's a second guy!
I think.
Actually, I can't tell.
HQ!
Nothing happened.
Ignore.
HQ, we don't care.
Can I go down from here?
Or will I break my leg?
Snake.
Dangle dangle.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
I don't trust it.
I don't trust.
Let's add some tiger stripe.
I think that actually only does better because we're by the tree, but whatever.
Is that a person?
No, that's a tree.
I'm scared.
I don't trust.
What if there's mines?
Can I even go this way?
I have to go around.
No trust in the jungle.
Exactly.
What the?
Oh shit.
Oh.
Oh, wait, who saw me?
Ah!
The dog!
I can't fight the dog.
Did I get him?
Get his butt?
Oh my god.
Shit.
Oh, they're seeing me.
No!
Oh my god.
Uh.
There we go.
They won't see me.
Oh, stupid dog.
You made me look bad.
What?
Can you see me?
Oh my god.
How can you see me?
I'm gonna eat this guy.
What can I say?
I have a gunshot wound.
I'm bleeding.
Disinfected.
What do I do?
Bleeding.
Um.
Ointment?
No.
Styptic.
And bandage.
Yes?
Oh!
Oh, that's cuts.
Oh, do I have to get it out?
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Do you think they'll step on me?
They're shooting at...
Something.
They have the...
They have...
They have that...
The spirit.
What are they shooting at?
Oh!
Oh, go away!
What?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Ah!
Shh!
Um...
Like, they see me, but they don't.
Like, they're kinda...
They're a little dumb.
They're a little silly.
I don't know if I can get him.
Oh, shit.
Um...
That's...
Okay.
You know what?
This is a...
A-okay.
Probably.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
He's running?
He must be hiding nearby.
Hunt him down.
Oh!
The dog is gone!
Oh, shit.
I should have paid attention to the dog.
I wasn't paying attention to the dog.
I hate the dogs!
Oh my god.
That guy scared me.
So bad.
Hello?
Because
of my...
Wait.
I have another one.
We're fine.
Poor dogs?
What about poor Minto?
Where's the dog?
The dog gets me every time.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Why did that guy just go be like, huh?
Why did he just freak out?
Why did he freak out?
Why did he freak out over there?
I didn't even do anything.
So, what's a good way to get rid of the dog?
What's a good strat for the dog?
Kill the dog!
Eat the dog!
Craw-cap?
Really?
Actually?
Does it actually work?
What if I craw-cap?
Crawl like a crocodile?
Is he going to be like, ow, ow?
Like, they can smell me.
I'm a gator.
Actually, I'm not a gator.
I'm a croc.
I'm a...
I'm a dilla.
Wait.
Dial.
He's like drooling everywhere.
Wait.
He actually thinks I'm a crocodile?
Oh.
It works.
Onwards.
Onwards, crocs.
I can't believe that works.
Where's the rest of our guys?
Caution's going to be over soon-ish, so.
If I run with the craw-cap, I'm going to die.
Does he still notice me, or is it just crawling?
It's so funny how this is...
They don't even think...
They don't even consider.
This is the real stealth mission.
I look so stealthy, for real.
I look like a real crocodile, I think, right now.
Hey.
Let's go.
I'm stuck.
I'm waiting for this guy to turn around.
Yeah, everybody leave, leave, leave.
Actually, where did he go?
He discovered a little cave or something.
Where did it...
Where's my man?
Oh man!
Oh there he is.
He doesn't come over here though does he?
Shit.
Maybe I can get him from like here.
If I can see him.
If I can smell him.
There we go.
Oh my god.
We got him guys.
We got him.
Don't worry about it.
What's that line for?
Let's see.
Sorry I'm a camo changer believer.
It's only five extra points but I'll do it.
Wait is that a... I see him over there.
I think I can get him.
Right there.
That is a guy though right?
Yeah that has to be a guy.
I think I can get him.
Don't think it was a mosquito.
Yeah just your imagination idiot.
Oh shit there's another guy.
Hmm.
Croc.
What did you see?
You see a standing crocodile man?
That would be...
Insanity.
No one would ever see that before.
What do you mean what's wrong?
Oh shit there's another guy.
Oh my god.
No!
What?
Why are there three guys all of a sudden?
Where did you guys come from?
Oh.
Uh.
Who was that?
Nobody.
Fucking shit!
Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Show me where the...
I think it worked.
Slam dunk baby.
It worked.
My poor suppressor.
Perfect stealth.
Exactly.
Oh I don't...
Oh let's take care of my uh...
Cut!
That's it you guys!
Just a cut!
We're bleeding?
Oh disinfectant.
Just a cut.
I'm so stealthy.
Doesn't matter.
Where...
Okay but seriously where did those other two guys come from?
Where did they come...
I didn't even notice them at all.
Where did they show up from?
Is that a guy down there?
I think so.
Back up for when the dog spotted you?
But no...
I wasn't in caution anymore.
So...
I'm not sure.
Oh.
I can get his back I think.
Just the wind.
Oh uh...
Actually...
Hold on.
Sick aim.
Sometimes...
I have my moments.
Okay.
Just my imagination.
Yeah just your imagination.
What is that?
Red dot.
What does that mean?
Fall asleep little baby.
Good night.
Red dot is a thing.
Awesome.
I think I can go in.
Anybody else around?
Oh not here.
My bad.
Anybody else around?
I'm a leaf.
I don't think it's a helicopter.
I'm a leaf with zero...
Uh...
Zero camouflage.
You got anything?
Nice.
Any suppressors?
Anybody got any suppressors?
Suppressor would be real nice right now.
You got...
Dang it.
Bullets for the gun I don't use?
No.
Guys I'm a...
I'm a pacifist.
I don't need a...
A weapon that...
Kills.
Water!
I don't think I've ever seen this uniform before.
What kind of water are we talking about?
Like...
Oh!
It's like...
Clear...
Effective when under water.
What?
It's like blue though.
This is like...
The water here has been yellow!
I think maybe that also is just the...
Um...
The...
What's the word?
Perhaps...
The...
The piss filter.
Oh!
There's a guy over there.
We're gonna get them all.
We're gonna take them out.
I could kill them.
But I'm...
I'm merciful.
Beep beep!
So whatever...
Is over there.
And here's something for the glasses fund.
What do you mean glasses fund?
What are you talking about?
I've gotten so many guys here!
I'm doing well!
Kind of.
Oh.
Uh...
Uchimeshimes.
Oh!
I hope...
No one...
Uh...
I hope no one's in here.
Okay.
Oh!
I found Kero-tan!
I found him.
Mousetrap.
What do I hear?
Oh, a suppressor.
Oh!
I feel like I'm hearing footsteps.
I'm just...
Maybe someone woke up.
You hear it?
Or is it just me?
It might be low for you.
Huh.
Could also be...
My imagination.
I could...
Be hearing an animal, maybe.
Okay.
Uh...
What's in here?
Oh!
Uh...
Rat!
Mousetrap.
And they're not doing very well.
Hello?
Can I get out of here?
Oh.
Where am I supposed to go?
Um...
Major?
I'm lost.
Snake.
That bird...
The building next to you is a provisions storehouse.
A provisions storehouse is where the enemy keeps their food.
Enemy units in that area use it to stock up on rations.
Uh!
So if you happen to blow up a provisions storehouse, the enemies in that area won't be able to get any more rations.
Spetsnaz are people too.
They gotta eat, or their stamina starts to go down.
I'm blowin' up.
They might pass out more easily or lose their concentration and start to shoot less accurately.
Oh!
Who knows?
They'll probably be a little more desperate for food just lying around.
Basically, if you get rid of the...
I can throw them snakes and stuff.
They gotta eat.
I got time and materials to spare, I believe.
Wait.
Actually, do I have materials to spare?
I have...
A claymore!
Wait, that won't do it.
I don't have anything.
A grenade, maybe?
Get the grenade.
Somebody's birthday?
Yesterday was my birthday.
I was hoping I'd get a happy birthday.
Brian!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Brian.
Happy birthday!
Some are saying that there's TNT in the area.
I think that was the door that I just shut.
I found a stone burning.
I want that, though.
What does the area include?
How big is the area we're talking about?
This guy still passed out.
Yeah.
Oh.
There we go.
Grenade.
You think I can just grenade it?
Maybe in here?
D-Med.
Oof-Med.
Antidote.
Bandage.
All things that I probably need.
Where's the shot?
Okay, let's try it.
I need TNT?
TNT?
Behind this building.
Nothing?
There's a guy here?
Where?
Oh, I see him.
Mine.
To the left?
I'm confused.
Oh, I see a build- Wait, no.
That leads into the cave.
There's nobody here.
Doesn't it?
Or maybe not.
Wait, I'm so confused.
No, cave- Sorry.
A cave is Ocelot.
So in here.
Okay, okay.
I'm thinking of- Wait.
Grenades.
No, geyser.
No.
There's no TNT.
Unless- I don't think I picked it up.
Weapon storage.
But there's no TNT.
Oh, that guy's dead.
That guy's awake.
Oh, it means everybody's probably awake now.
No.
I did.
I got it.
Oh, but it's gonna be so risky.
Snake, that building next to you is an enemy armory.
As you might have guessed, those armories you sometimes run into are where they keep their ammo and other stuff.
I got it.
I didn't even see it.
If you take out an armory, the enemy units in the area will have their ammo supply cut off.
It was covered up by all the other techs then.
And if they know they're on their last leg, they'll use ammo a little more sparingly in a gunfight.
Bottom line, it's a good idea.
Bottom line, if you blow up an armory, the enemy's firepower decreases.
By destroying an armory, you can cut off the enemy's supply of ammunition.
That should make your job a lot easier.
I can't remember what I'm supposed to do here, though.
Good.
You've reached the relay station.
Yeah.
But stay alert.
That station is an enemy strong point.
The security is bound to be tight.
Yeah, it is.
But there's no other way to get to the crevice if I don't make it through.
Exactly.
The crevice.
That's where we fight Ocelot.
The crevice leading to the cave is in the north of that area.
Yeah.
Find a way to slip past the enemy and head north.
North?
You can blow up the helicopter, too?
Wait, does that make it so then that cliffside area, they don't bother you?
No way.
That would be huge.
Yes, actually.
Oh, what the hell?
Please.
Oh, my inventory.
Destroy it.
Let's destroy everything.
They're going to get really mad at me.
I got it.
TNT.
Yippee.
Okay, how do we use?
Where do I put it on the chopper?
Press to set square.
Press circle to detonate.
I can't tell who's awake and who's asleep, you know?
Under the helicopter.
Press against the chopper to place.
Press against where?
I might need to get this guy again.
My suppressor is not doing so hot you guys.
I'm kind of nervous.
Kind of nervous.
I think that guy can see me.
I can't tell.
I'm going to change.
I'm going to take off my clothes.
Right in front of him.
To the olive drab.
Where did he go?
There's like no way to press against it though, right?
I don't feel.
Also, where do I go here?
I don't remember at all.
So like right here maybe.
What was it?
Okay, set.
Okay.
I'll be back.
Set it on the sheds too.
I do want to set it in...
At least, well I guess I can do this one.
I'm already here, right?
Oh my gosh, I'm so loud.
Beep.
Okay.
I'm hungry.
We have so much food, so I'm not even going to be...
I'm not even going to be like...
This tastes great.
I'm not even going to be frugal.
I'm going to be like, let's go.
Camo.
Thunderstrike.
Going with the T.
Is this guy awake again?
Yes.
I see him.
Now if I blow up the first one, they'll all run to the...
Helicopter.
Assuming.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
You know what?
Maybe they won't.
Who knows, actually.
That's wishful thinking, isn't it?
We'll get more people.
Wait.
Yeah, I'm going to do them all at once.
I just got to...
I'm going to get to the exit and then go bam, bam, bam.
Which, wherever the exit is, I...
Wait, is that it right there?
I found the exit.
I don't want to get seen by that guy.
Okay.
I think we're okay right now.
Open up.
Okay.
Plenty.
Try looting.
Hope find another suppressor.
It's okay if I don't.
I'll just be.
I'll just...
You know.
I'll just be.
I don't think that guy over here will notice me.
Okay.
Before we go...
Let's do it behind the tree.
There we go.
So this guy can't see me here.
Look, I can see you.
This is HQ Bye.
This is HQ This is HQ See ya.
Oh, god.
It's time for a little...
I think this is correct.
Well, we're here...
Therefore...
Oh, my...
Look like the boss's info is right.
It has a dandy robot.
W slot This is just too much.
Wahh.
Twice now, you've made me taste bitter defeat.
I know.
Hey, chill out guys!
This is our fight!
Oh my gosh, we got the Ocelot Squad, we got the regular guys...
Why did you call them out then?
Why did you call them out?
It's just you and me.
Yeah, it is.
No one to get in our way.
Ocelots are proud creatures.
They prefer to hunt alone.
Oh my gosh!
I'm like a monkey, I see someone do something, I'm like...
12 shots.
He's like, yeah, I used to have 6 shots, now I got 12 shots.
Dummy.
Yeah, keep going!
Keep going!
This time I've got 12 shots.
I clapped when I saw Ocelot.
Oh my gosh!
The tension.
The tension, baby.
Draw!
Okay.
Give me a second, Ocelot.
Let me get behind this rock.
Okay.
One second.
Do I...
I don't want to use my ache, I mean...
I'll take off my suppressor.
You can do that with revolvers too, right boss?
Yeah.
Do we want the camo?
What, naked?
Wait, is there like a camo here?
Will Mint have better accuracy than the pouch he saw?
Find out... find out next time.
On the next episode of Dragon Ball Z.
If you tranquilize him, he gets special camo.
Ah!
What?
Wait, what's the camo?
Oh.
Naked with the zombie face paint.
Zombie, zombie.
It's more like...
It's more like that skull guy from...
What's it called?
Call of Duty, right?
Oh, the animal camo!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Alright.
Okay, well then let me...
Ghost!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, how could I forget that name?
Where are you?
Oh,
I should probably equip my gun.
Oh, he's reloading and I'm not doing anything.
I'm wasting my opportunity.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Sorry, I lost a lot.
Oh gosh.
Okay, I gotta get my bearings.
Okay, I gotta actually...
Pay attention and play the game.
Wait,
can I get down from here, please?
Oh my gosh.
Who are you talking to?
Ouch!
Oh god!
Oh my god!
I'm not okay.
It's going to be so good.
I'm such a freak.
Wait, how did I get poisoned?
I think I'm in love.
What's wrong with me?
Venom poisoning.
Oh, I think I got bit by a snake.
I have to do the serum.
Um...
Wait, is it under here?
Oh, here we go.
This guy... I don't think I've ever got bit before.
This guy is such a freak.
I cannot stand him.
Ouch!
This snake again!
You son of a bitch.
Yeah.
Die.
Ocelot, I'm fighting my own battles here.
Please.
You freakazoid.
You are such a little freak.
You are such a freak.
I love you so much, you my little freak.
Wait.
Dang it.
Oh.
Where
is he?
Where did he go?
Oh.
I keep shooting!
Such an idiot.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm actually so stupid.
Sorry guys.
Wait.
My brain is not okay right now.
I'm not even doing anything.
I'm not.
I think he... whatever.
Stay outside.
You are such a freak.
You are so freaky.
You are such a little weirdo.
Where are you?
Where did you go my little weirdo?
Isn't there a... Oh.
Wait.
Hold on.
I almost got him.
Come back out.
I need...
Oh.
He is... struggling right now.
Ouch!
I don't
remember.
How did I do this before?
Oh my gosh.
I... Thank you.
Oh.
The release.
The button release kills me sometimes.
I know.
I see you.
I see you my little freak.
Where are you?
Did you leave?
You left me.
Trust your instincts as a gamer.
Any freaks or little weirdos in the chat?
You are so thrilling in the middle of the battle.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Please!
I... Did I get his hat?
No way.
Yeah.
His hat is off.
I think I just got him in the balls.
Yeah.
You did.
I think you...
Yeah.
He died.
Oh my god.
I'm only good at like one angle.
Where are you?
Reloading.
There you are.
Freak!
I love you so much, freak.
Ah!
Shit!
You fool!
Oh.
There he is.
You fool!
Damn.
Oh my god.
Why do I...
Just let him keep going.
Oh my god.
Stop touching it like that.
That's a lot.
Oh my gosh.
It was so weird.
I think I could have gotten in there but I chickened out.
I chickened out.
No.
I know.
I'm chickening out.
I'm not going to fight you, coward.
Ah!
Not bad.
He's getting faster?
I don't think so.
Thank you for teaching me the joy of the long run.
He's so weird.
He's so...
He's actually so weird.
He's so weird.
Bastard.
Oh, I can't reach.
He's so close.
Come on.
Come back.
Oh, there's bees.
I'm not okay.
Oh my gosh.
Had enough yet?
No, no.
You bastard.
You're all gone, huh?
Oh my god.
Oh, it's grenades.
Stop shooting me.
Thank you.
Thank you for teaching me the joy of the long run.
Stand unopened.
Stand in the open unarmed for a special seat?
No way.
I can't tell if I'm getting trolled or not.
The Russian jungle is straight up reloading it.
Damn.
By it, I mean my remal.
Do it.
Oh, I didn't even get trolled.
Oh, my god.
My...
I did get trolled.
The way he says it.
Stop, Ocelot.
I can't take this anymore.
Please.
My mind is melting right now.
I'm losing it.
I'm losing my mind.
It's a revolution.
I can't take this anymore.
What happened to the duel?
Oh, I had it equipped.
I had it equipped.
That's why.
No, I missed it!
Because I have my gun.
Oh yeah, now he's reflecting.
He's getting stronger.
He's getting harder.
No, I'm scared!
I'm scared!
Can you see me if I climb up here?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
You are such a weirdo!
Alright, Commander!
Oh my god.
You feeling it, Ocelot?
I can't tell where he stopped.
Hold on.
My health is not bad, but...
I think...
I'll eat it.
I'll eat a little ink cap.
Sick!
Tasted bad.
Stop edging him.
I really am not meaning it.
I'm just... I'm just bad at this... I'm just bad at game.
Oh, there he is.
I'm just... I'm just bad at game, okay?
Where did he go?
I'm just bad at aiming and gaming!
God,
you son of a...
God...
Son of...
The boss...
Son of a...
You're such a...
You should not be named Ocelot.
You should be named Weasel.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Okay, it's off, huh?
Like this?
It's a revolution.
Where is your head?
Oh, there.
Shit.
What?
Here what comes?
Wait, the music quieted down for a second.
What happened?
That was weird.
Are there still some bees left?
I don't think so.
Oh, there is!
Okay, so...
When he goes on that side...
Come back over here, Ocelot.
Come back over here.
You're reloading?
Oh my god.
Oh see, I knocked his hat off again!
That was so close.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, how romantic.
We both got each other.
I'm just playing with him.
That's why I took his hat down instead of...
Oh my gosh.
Snake, I'm gonna need you to look the right way, please.
Thank you.
Thank you for teaching me the joy of the Revolver.
Oh my gosh, please.
Controller!
My hands are too small!
My hands are too small to grip!
Oh, there he is.
He does that.
I'll do.
Oh, did I?
I don't think I got him.
It's so messed up.
Oh my god.
Where do you go?
Little freak.
Oh, I think he left me.
I think he left.
Oh my gosh, he's over there.
It's perfect.
Shut up!
Shut up out there!
You!
What are you doing there?
Oh, Kero-tan.
Yeah, that's right.
Ouch!
Hold on.
Hold on!
Snake, I need you to, like, recover faster, okay?
Okay, I complain.
Oh my gosh, please.
Ocelot, you're going too fast, okay?
Oh wait, he's over there?
So maybe...
Now?
No, not now.
Oh.
Where are you going?
Oh my god, please.
What?!
Stop!
Major!
Forgive me.
Distract him with the croc hat?
You think he'd like that?
I'm going up here.
Oh my god, look how bloodied I am!
Oh my god!
I'm proud!
Stupid...
controller!
Oh no, time for the bees!
Oh no!
The bees!
Oh no, the bit rate!
Yeah,
that's what you get for shooting at me earlier!
Why'd you take off your mask?
Oh my god!
You watched all your friends die and you didn't think to leave?
Why didn't he do this in battle when the bees were around?
You were lucky.
We'll meet again.
I'm wearing this stupid-ass face paint.
I forgot to turn it off.
Ghost from 1964.
Oh, we're in the caves!
Oh gosh.
We're in the caves.
Can't see anything.
Oh, it's actually so dark.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, whoops.
You were lucky.
Wait, how does zombie paint give me more advantage?
Wait, oh gosh, it's so dark.
Oh, actually, I have them equipped, don't I?
Alright, everybody.
Watch your eyes.
Oh, gosh!
Okay, it doesn't really do that much help.
We can at least see the snake in here.
What is this?
It's a...
Snake!
It's a... Is this the crab?
Crab!
Something crab battle.
Crab battle.
Oh, in fact, I know what we can do.
Snake, are you okay?
Snake!
Major.
Snake.
Are you alright?
You're not hurt?
No.
That was a hell of a drop, but I'm fine.
Looks like there's no way back up, though.
Yeah.
I see.
Well, anyway, it's good to hear you're not injured.
Slipping and falling may not have been part of the plan, but getting into that cave was.
Yeah.
Proceed further into the cave.
Okay.
The cave seems to be structured like a maze, but there's an exit somewhere.
Find a way out of the cave and head for the aqueduct.
Aqueduct.
Okay.
Oh, I...
The cave seems to be structured like a maze, but...
Got it.
Pyromatic, I'm gonna save real quick.
You wanna save?
Yeah.
Hold on a sec.
Okay.
Save!
I forget sometimes I save.
I should be saving more often, honestly, because I'm scared of it.
Save!
It's loading.
Okay.
Snake, have you seen 007 from Russia with Love?
Nah, I don't like those movies.
Real spies are nothing like James Bond.
It's pure fantasy.
Pure fantasy.
Snake, I don't think the Major's going to like you saying that.
Mmm.
And even though it's...
The glowing mushrooms are in that cave, right?
Yes!
In here.
What exactly don't you like about James Bond?
I mean, is it the fantastic gadgets?
The cars?
The guns?
Major.
Major!
Wouldn't you like to have a gun shaped like a pen?
That's a cute...
What good is a pen gonna do me in the jungle?
Yeah!
I'd look like a fool.
Then what about a snake-shaped gun?
Ooh.
You could make it look like you're grappling with a giant snake and then get a shot in on the enemy while they're distracted.
Okay, that kinda sounds awesome.
Okay, now you're being ridiculous.
What?!
We'll make you a snake-shaped gun that folds up and fits into an attach case.
Will you give it a rest?
Oh, I get it.
Get on it!
You're all about how to handle the ladies, aren't you?
No.
I knew it.
To tell you the truth, I don't like the idea of playing hanky-panky with enemy femme fatales either.
Hanky-panky?
But that's part of Bond's appeal.
You could learn a thing or two from him.
I mean, what about this Eva?
What are you planning to do with her?
I don't even trust her.
Yeah!
What do you mean, do with her?
You can't let yourself get involved.
This is a game of spy versus spy.
She's using you just as much as you're using her.
I mean, sure, yeah, but...
You've got to grab the initiative.
Planning to press R what?
That's what a spy is supposed to do.
Get the upper hand.
I don't think I'm cut out for that mission.
Hanky-panky.
Maybe if you change your code name to 00 Snake.
007 is the biggest thing to come out of England since the Mayflower.
I wouldn't be surprised if they made 20 more of those movies.
00 Snake!
Didn't you know?
The Major is a huge James Bond fan.
Man, don't get him worked up like this.
Worked up?
Maybe you don't realize this, but now that you've got him started talking about Bond, I'm going to have to listen to him lecture for a whole hour after he gets off the radio.
You have my sympathy.
It's too bad you can't enjoy such a great movie, though.
I guess I'm just one of those people who can't enjoy spy flex.
You'd think that like...
Okay, actually, I don't know.
Do some people enjoy... like you... like...
Do some people... I guess it depends on like the occupation.
If you would... Do you think you would enjoy a movie about your occupation?
Because I feel like for me, it's like...
Not only would I relate to it, but I'd also be able to like kind of take myself out of the movie.
I don't know.
Depends.
Bond is 20 plus movies, but Godzilla is 30 plus?
No, really?
My job is boring AF.
I mean...
A VTuber movie.
I don't know if I would watch...
Okay, I would watch a VTuber movie.
I would not watch a streamer movie.
Big difference there, huh?
Oh my gosh, we're already... We're all the way back to the survival knife.
V movie.
Streamer movie would be cringe.
Yeah, pretty much.
Yeah,
there is a VTuber anime.
I haven't watched... Oh, there's a couple.
Kind of.
You're right.
With your knife, you don't have to worry about it breaking no matter how much you swing it around.
So the important thing is durability.
Man, I gotta write this stuff down.
See?
I told you, Sigyn's taking notes.
Next time, I'll make you see if the matches and fish hooks go in the sheath instead.
Gone fishing.
Oh my gosh.
Um...
Can't I... Oh, wait!
I can use the cigar, I forgot!
Oh, but my health...
I don't think cigars are highly addictive, right?
I think that's not real.
It doesn't give me so much...
Oh gosh.
Okay, hold on.
Let's try the sonar.
Wait, the sonar does animals sound waves.
Going
towards the red dot.
Motion detector.
Wow!
This cave is crawling.
I seriously can't see anything.
There are also torches.
Yeah, I just don't remember where...
I have to...
I can't see any...
I can't even get out of this room to check out the torches.
Um...
No!
I thought cigars don't have nicotine in them.
Am I wrong?
Oh, okay.
I'm in a wall.
All right.
Uh...
Okay.
This way.
Wait, am I back where I started?
Wait.
This way.
Okay.
We're making progress.
This way.
Come on, snake!
Oh my gosh!
It's the things!
It's the glow!
I see you've caught yourself a Kenyan mangrove crab.
Oh, I did, yeah.
The Kenyan mangrove crab is a land-going crab.
It lives in burrows dug near seashores and mangrove swamps.
It's not poisonous, but it might hurt a little if it attacks you with its pincers.
Treat it with caution.
Crab battle.
Got it.
So this thing must taste pretty good, huh?
Yeah.
Why do you say, must?
Because it's a crab.
It's a crab, isn't it?
It is.
And crabs are good to eat.
Yeah.
What's so good about them?
You don't like crab?
Not at all.
What?
Why not?
Why?
How can you eat those things?
They're all purple and yellow-striped.
And they stink.
They stink like cat pee.
What?
But that's just my opinion.
Don't listen to me.
Let's see here.
The guide says...
Wait, what?
No way.
It says they're delicious.
Well, if you want to eat one, then go right ahead, but count me out.
What do you mean it smells like cat pee?
Wait, what?
What crab is she talking about?
What?
She said it was yellow and purple?
It smells like cat pee.
Ammonia from the decay.
I see you cut yourself a rat.
The rats in that area are the descendants of the wild Norway rats that were domesticated by humans as pets and lab ants.
Wait, the mushroom!
They're not poisonous, and I don't think they'll live long.
They'll attack you.
But they're quick little creatures, so you might have a hard time catching them.
I was watching that pekoro clip like just the other day.
Snake.
Rat.
They're rats.
I know what they are.
Do they taste okay?
Okay.
Rat.
The guide says they're not that bad.
Good enough for me.
I see you found some Russian glow caps.
Here it is.
A mushroom glow cap is a kind of luminescent fungus.
A mushroom that glows in the dark.
Why would a mushroom glow in the dark?
It's bioluminescent, just like a firefly.
It uses the so-called luciferin-luciferase reaction.
Luciferin-luciferase.
To put it simply, luciferin reacts with luciferase in the presence of magnesium 2 plus ions, breaking it down into oxy-luciferin and carbon dioxide.
He's scratching his face.
He's so confused.
I'm never...
The carbon groups in the oxy-luciferin are initially in an electrical excited state.
I've never noticed that before.
Did you get all that?
Not really.
By the way, does that mushroom recharge your batteries when you eat it?
I mean, it seems like if you ate a glowing mushroom, it might recharge your batteries or something.
Snake, your batteries are organic batteries.
They produce electricity by utilizing the potential difference between cells.
Organic batteries are known for their highly efficient energy conversion.
But they still rely on chemical reactions between proteins and enzymes to...
So you're saying they'll get recharged.
Believe what you want.
Great.
He's so excited about it.
Eva.
Snake, are you all right?
Yeah, just barely.
What the hell were all those hornets?
She's 28.
Most likely that was the pain, one of the cobras.
I figured as much.
Are they tracking me?
I don't know.
The cobras only take orders from the boss.
Not even Volgin knows what they're really up to.
So I don't know anything about them either.
They're just chilling.
They're just freaky guys.
Literally the freak circus.
You just focus on moving ahead.
Go to the end of the cave and you'll come out in an aqueduct overgrown with mangroves.
Okay.
This leads to the Ponyzovye Swamp.
Ponyzovye.
And Snake, be careful.
She's from Idaho?
So random.
Any Meridian, Idaho people here?
You are living in a legendary location.
I heard there's some emergency torches stored somewhere in that cave.
Yeah, where?
Torches.
Got it.
So where are they?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
Where are the torches?
How should I know?
Go find them yourself.
Eva!
Alright, let's eat a mushroom.
Let's recharge our battery, you guys.
The Bokomomokos.
I wish I had more of those.
Look at the rats.
The Bokomomokos.
Wait, what does it say?
Said to recharge the battery.
Battery has recovered.
Apparently the Bokomomokos taste bad.
No way, really?
Oh wait, I do remember Snake saying that, right?
Even though they're like a fruit?
She's a snake.
What's up?
You were right.
About what?
I ate a Russian glow cap and it charged up my batteries.
Huh?
What's wrong?
I...
That's...
That's great.
Um...
Snake, can you excuse me for a second?
Sure.
Did you just hear that?
Yeah.
There's no way eating a bioluminescent mushroom would cause your batteries to recharge.
I mean...
What do you think it means?
Beast meat.
Beast meat?
Maybe it's all in his mind.
The power of the mind...
You mean like a placebo effect?
...is strong.
Why not?
You've seen how gullible he is.
He's not gullible!
Should we let him keep believing it?
Sounds good to me.
What?
Okay, Snake.
I'm back.
Yes.
The Russian glow cap is a glowing mushroom.
So it'll recharge your batteries when you eat it.
The head tilt!
Oh, he's so cute.
What a guy.
Motion D.
Let's see what animals we got in here.
Oh!
A grenade!
The bullet!
Uh...
I'm running somewhere?
Oh gosh.
This is so...
What the hell?
Why is the wall warm?
Look at his head!
Oh my god!
There is gotta be some heat on that headband.
Are you telling me that there's...
That the headband is just like made of ice?
What is this?
It's cutting off the blood circulation.
What is this for real?
It's not hot at all.
There's nothing going on in there.
Yeah, I could have really used that this summer, for real.
Okay.
Oh, what's this?
Oh.
Some crabs, maybe?
Is this where we first started, you think?
I'm trying to see if I can like...
Follow where animals are.
Okay, we're going somewhere, maybe?
Maybe not?
Okay.
Is this it?
I think this is where I just came from, right?
With the Russian...
Glow caps.
Or maybe not.
Maybe this is different.
Yes!
This is where I just was!
No!
Snake always keeps a cool head in battle.
Check your map?
I'm gonna be honest.
I 100% forgot I had a map.
I...
100% forgot I had a map.
100%.
Thank you.
Same.
There's a map?
I 100% forgot there's a map here.
Holy moly.
Okay, so now we go over this way.
Like over here.
Right, not in front of me, but...
Okay, a little over.
Ow!
No, this map is not useless at all!
What are you talking about?
It's so helpful!
We found the area!
Do you think...
Did I miss...
Okay, hold on.
Before we go in there...
There's like this whole...
There's like this whole big blobby room right down there.
Sorry, hold on.
I know I keep having to open it.
I just want to make sure I'm going the right way.
Okay, to the other side.
It says I've been in there, but...
No!
No, no!
Turn around!
Did you see the Blair Witch Project?
I don't think I've ever...
I think I've actually only seen it once.
I'm lost.
I have a map, but I'm lost.
This room?
That's what I'm trying to see.
If the torches are in this blobby room.
Okay.
Wait, am I in the blobby room?
I thought I...
That's where I fell down?
Understandable.
Okay.
We'll keep onwards then.
Is it through here?
Me opening this damn map every two seconds?
Okay, yes.
Okay.
Torches on the left side.
Ah!
I can see!
Oh my gosh.
I can see.
Why is this like amnesia?
Why are there just some...
A torch!
Light or put out fire with the square.
And... Oh!
Mushroom!
Time for mushrooms!
Mushroom, mushroom, get the  Mush!
Random mushrooms!
sizes!
Mushroom!
It's not going to spoil.
No, it won't!
We can see!
This way.
Okay,
give me one second.
Before we do that.
Actually, yeah.
I'll go do that.
We're saved!
We got the torch.
Everything's good.
Everything's fine.
Where is the blob?
Is this the blob area?
Is this where I fell?
Oh, there it is!
Ah, my nose.
Wait, what's here?
Wait, this is the other one that I went down before, right?
No, this is a secret.
What's in here?
What are those?
What are these?
Frogs?
Okay...
Let's check over here first.
Did you win yet?
Yep!
I had a feeling that would happen.
I don't think I can climb that.
I don't see anything at the bottom.
Actually, I'm going to be a genius real quick.
Can you imagine if that, like, electrocuted you?
There are things at the bottom!
Oh, my God.
Stuff that I don't even need!
I thought I was a genius.
I really thought.
I know there's a hole here.
I guess we'll go through.
I can't remember where it goes to.
Apparently, this is Phantom Pain.
I mean, look who's playing.
I'm a phantom.
I'm in pain.
Have a nice day.
.
What is here?
Is that a ration?
There's like a frog touching me.
Oh my gosh.
Ration!
My food is full!
Woah!
Look up.
We're in a hole.
Oh my god, the sun!
But we can't do anything in here, so...
Oh, do you think the keroutan is in this area?
Oh,
the sun is here too.
Keroutan is like in one of these.
I know it.
As a ghost, aren't you like allergic to the sun?
I'm not a vampire!
Ghosts can't go out in the sun!
It's a common misconception that ghosts only show up at night.
I mean, we're around all the time.
Yeah, I hate garlic.
What is that?
What is that on the ground?
It's a...
Hoop?
It was...
This one.
Oh my god!
I didn't even notice there was... oh wait.
I was right.
Why didn't you attack me before?
You guys.
I was correct.
Correct.
Let's go to the other one, because... yeah.
There's a little wall.
I remember now.
Here.
Yes.
Why are there skeletons?
People die!
All the time.
Oh.
I didn't necessarily want to fall down here.
But we did.
No way.
It took me all the way back here!
Oh my gosh.
It wasn't even anything that special.
Glowberry.
My food is full!
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, battery!
Actual battery.
It's OK, because we can eat.
We can eat up.
Eat up, eat up, eat up.
Eat up, eat up, eat up, eat up.
Let's taste the bread.
OK.
Bread.
What did he say about it?
Pretty good?
I'm going to buy the $240 Jetstream Sam Sword Replica Man.
No!
That's mine!
Wait.
$200?
Why is there so much cheaper?
Where did you find it for $200?
Wait a second.
I found one.
But it's like way more expensive.
OK.
Time to go all the way back.
All the way back.
Alrighty.
Don't fall.
I learned my lesson.
Exploring doesn't pay, you guys.
Yes, it does.
Just kidding.
Exploring pays!
Frog.
I can't attack with him.
Is this where all the crabs are?
That I got to fight?
The little pinchers?
Oh my gosh!
Why is it so hard to find my knife?
Yeah, don't come towards me.
Is this Nutty Putty Cave?
I sure hope so.
Serum.
Cool.
Oh, OK.
We'll be coming to here later.
Anything else up here?
A little bit, yeah.
Anything else?
No.
Nutty Putty Cave.
Would you guys...
Would you guys do cave diving?
You'll end up like this guy.
Not Snake.
The one in the bottom right.
Not me.
You'll end up dead.
Like that other guy.
But also not me.
You'll end up dead.
End up like Minto.
Pika Minto.
There was stuff in the other cave that we didn't check yet.
Should we go back?
This can't all be secret.
Right?
Big ol' snake.
Oh, bats?
Don't wanna eat those.
Who's attacking me?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Let's go back.
Nope, nope, nope, nope.
Not yet.
Not yet,
not yet.
No, not time for bees.
I wanna explore just a little tiny bit more.
If you guys are okay with it.
A shotgun.
Nice.
Is there any suppressors in here?
Bats, leave me alone.
Don't they attack?
Leave me alone.
Here we go.
This must be where the crabs are.
Crabs.
Oh, crabs.
Where art thou, crab?
Snow uniform.
Use the sonar.
No, it's okay.
Ribbit, ribbit.
Ribbit, ribbit, ribbit.
Ribbit.
Any time snakes tell me growls...
Oh!
Mine does too, though.
Just a little bit.
Ah!
He came after me first.
It was self-defense.
That's self-defense.
Let's eat all of our food.
Let's eat all the stuff...
that we got.
What can I say?
That looks like a crab.
Crab battle!
This cave is huge, man.
It's so...
big.
Where even are we?
I'm on a murdering spree.
I can't stop murdering crabs.
Where are we?
Oh, gosh.
The bats.
Leave me alone.
Hold on.
Okay.
Never mind.
My eyes deceived me.
I thought that was a way up.
Oh, gosh.
I was so blew away.
Leave me alone.
How am I...
I haven't gone through here before.
I have not.
I have!
It's a big old loop.
That's it.
We've been bamboozled.
But there was that one area we didn't go to.
Okay,
we have literally nothing.
Um, what haven't we gotten in the caves?
We haven't gotten the bats?
I guess I can get one now.
Come here, bat!
Bat!
How do I... Kill the bat!
Kill the bat!
Oh, there we go.
I wasn't even...
I was EQC-ing the bats instead of actually killing them.
I think I killed all the bats.
I think I killed all of them.
I'm going to...
Throw away...
We haven't eaten our crabs yet, but they're said to be tasty, so we'll keep it.
That was tasty.
The arowana's tasty.
We'll throw away the crocodile.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Paramedic!
I got a bat.
A vampire bat?
Ah, sucker.
Sucker.
Got it.
Speaking of bats...
Hey, I'm a freaker.
Just say it.
Huh?
I know you're going to talk about vampire movies.
Oh, that's right.
Attack of the Vampire Donuts, or Dracula vs.
the Space Hippos, or something like that.
I forgot.
He hates vampires.
Actually, I was going to say that bats are known to use supersonic waves to sense their surroundings.
He hates...
He hates the bats.
I mean, he hates the vampire.
Bats use supersonic waves to sense their surroundings, so you might be able to keep them away by blasting them with a special kind of sound wave.
Alternatively, you could try equipping a torch and waving it around with the CQC button.
As for taste, I suppose there's no reason you couldn't eat them.
Snake, do you hate vampire movies?
What?
Just now, you sounded like you really hated them.
I did?
Yeah.
Oh.
Well, no one really likes them, do they?
Some people do.
Like you.
Yeah.
They're fascinating, you know?
Like the movie Dracula.
Don't say it.
Why not?
Just don't.
Are you afraid?
What?
You're afraid of vampires, aren't you?
My body's afraid of vampires.
Don't be ridiculous.
But...
Listen.
There are no such things as vampires.
That's not what we said.
It's just a stupid made-up legend.
And if they do seem real sometimes...
Well, sure.
You think I'd be afraid of something like that?
No.
Exactly.
Right.
Makes me wish there was, like, a vampire-like boss in this game.
It's just that whenever somebody starts talking about vampires, I end up dreaming about them that night.
I don't need that right now.
I don't need that.
Oh, man.
What a silly guy.
So silly.
I don't need that right now.
Oh, my bad.
There we go.
Let's go back.
Wait.
Hold on a second.
Checking my map.
Yeah.
So we haven't been down there.
Or we have.
No.
We gotta go back.
Wait.
What's over...
Yeah, yeah.
This is where we're going.
Wait.
Huh?
This is why we never got an MGS Castlevania crossover.
So...
This part...
Right here...
Isn't that where I just came from?
Maybe that's the exit to the...
Let's show it.
No.
The top is where we just came from.
Huh?
I'm so confused.
What is that area that's not explored?
But then also down here.
That big old blob we haven't explored.
I'm lost.
Oh, you didn't hear the chew.
Sorry.
It's because I have to...
Otherwise you'll get the double audio.
So I keep it...
I...
Turn it off.
Sorry.
I can't.
I think he's alive.
Are you alive?
Are you gonna move?
I think he's dead.
He's alive!
Self-defense.
I don't think technically we've gotten that guy either.
I don't wanna waste all my good food.
Little frog.
Little little little cave frog.
Alright.
Where... are we?
Where are we?
So there was another way to get close?
Let's just go the long way, I guess.
Which is this way?
I'm a little lost.
Wait a second!
Where?
This is where we dropped...
And I was headed this way and then I got distracted.
I was headed this way.
Right?
Wait.
Not this way.
I was headed the other direction.
Then I got lost.
I was headed this way.
Very clearly.
Then I was going this way.
Yes!
And then I wanted to go this way.
So this is... up here.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is where I wanted to go.
But then there's also this big blob here.
Okay.
We'll figure it out.
And there's some more...
Some more batteries.
Wait.
Can I even take this?
I don't think I can.
No!
You know what?
It's fine.
We got enough, probably.
And here we go.
Okay.
Forward.
Not march crawl.
Forward crawl.
Oh.
Come at me.
Vampires.
Bisexuals.
Crab battle.
Why isn't it called bat battle?
What does this hold to?
This is literally spelunking down here.
Snake, you're getting deep.
You're getting in deep.
I'm scared for you.
Bat battle.
Here we go.
Crawling on through.
That's a crab.
Just avoid him.
Actually, was it a crab?
I might.
My eyes may have deceived me.
Where are we, Snake?
Where are we?
Context?
What do you mean, context?
For what?
Context for what?
Oh, and this is...
That big old blobby room I wanted to check out.
Oh, that's the hole!
Don't fall in.
Night vision goggles!
Now you guys can shut up about it.
Kettle time!
We're done!
Ribbit.
And then if you look up, there's the light.
Snake, you're looking a little pale.
You're looking a little like...
A vampire.
He's becoming his worst enemy.
Would it be faster to go all the way back or to fall through the hole, I wonder?
Fall through the hole.
Wee!
Alright, you guys ready?
You guys ready for some bees?
I remember this fight being...
Not the worst.
But...
Just a tad...
Annoying for me.
Because of my depth perception.
So I shall...
Do my best.
Fear all who see me.
Okay, here we go.
You got the shotgun.
It's useful.
And here's your water camo.
Have fun.
Thanks, Wes!
How much was the one that I found?
It was like...
It was in...
It was in Yen.
But in dollars, it was $500.
500 USD.
And I was like, this is...
I really want it.
But obviously, that's a lot of money.
So I've just been like...
I just have the tab open.
And I've just been looking at it every day.
I was just like, oh my gosh.
What if one day on stream, I just pulled it out?
I just whipped it out.
I was like, this isn't even my sword.
What if I just did that, you know?
Yeah.
Just casually whipped it out.
What if?
Yeah.
Well, it's expensive.
I found it's 300-ish.
Oh.
Well, it's also...
It seems to be...
What's the word?
It seems to be handmade.
Like, it seems to be like a cosplay prop.
So...
I don't know.
It looks really fancy, though.
I have no idea what it's made out of.
Is it...
Snake?
Have you heard of The Last War?
The Last War?
No.
It doesn't ring a bell.
I actually don't know this one.
It's a Japanese movie where the world ends in a nuclear war.
Oh.
Tensions between East and West reach the breaking point.
And before anyone can stop it, they launch the ICBMs.
Oh.
Humanity is wiped out by a war that no one wanted.
The movie depicts that destruction from the eyes of ordinary people.
Oh.
I don't know.
Their simple daily lives are torn apart by the terrible power of a war that has nothing to do with them.
Everybody's afraid of the next big war.
But there's only so much that one person can do.
That's why the people who have the power to stop it have to.
The torrents.
Okay.
That got so serious.
It was this way, right?
Yeah.
I love you.
Don't look.
It's okay.
Mom tell me that you learned the deployers' moves.
I'm not good at your stuff.
Dad, you're just  ...
It's okay.
I'm came to find out the delicious world of Earth from Earth.
My dreams are more valuable when asked.
Don't look.
This is him doing Otage.
He's like...
I thought we were playing Metal Gear, not karaoke.
That was literally a Metal Gear song!
Oh my gosh, freedom!
Can you smell?
Can you smell the air?
The fresh air?
Oh, my nose is...
Alright.
Let's go.
I hate the smell of bees.
Something about... some bug smell is so bad.
No!
What about Matara?
That's why...
Bee... not bee...
Yeah!
Burger!
Oh yeah.
He's so tokusatsu.
The world of anguish beyond your imagination.
The pain.
For some reason, I always call this guy the Fury.
Like my brain...
Let's get started.
...knows who he is.
Okay.
What was the trick for this one again?
Let's see.
Oh!
No!
Oh my gosh!
I'm stinky!
I'm smelly!
One second.
I'm just gonna drown under here.
Let's see.
So if I change...
Water...
Wow!
I like this...
So much!
Wait.
I can't... How do I... There we go.
I like this one so much!
Wow!
Actually looks so good!
Okay.
I don't think face... Yeah.
Do I have in my arsenal...
I have stun grenades, but I don't have grenade grenades.
So let's change that.
I'm gonna get rid of the stun grenade, so I don't accidentally click on it.
Because I would, baby!
I would!
And...
You want that shotty.
Oh!
The shotgun!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The M37.
Oh, shoot!
So now...
I throw grenade at him.
Okay.
Press square to hold.
Release to throw.
Oh, fuck!
The Tommy gun!
Stop!
Go down!
No!
No, no, no!
No, no!
Tommy gun!
If I try and shoot him right now...
Oh, I can't shoot him.
In the water.
That's so unfortunate.
The fish.
I love when all the fish die.
It's so funny.
Okay, hold on.
I have to remember how to do this fight.
It's always the grenades, man.
They're always the grenades.
Look at me.
What's up?
We got a burn ointment.
What did we do?
The bandage.
Okay, we're good.
Take your time, Minto.
Thank you!
There he is!
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
This is so sad!
Oh my gosh, my...
Holy cow.
Air awareness!
And I know this one tasted bad.
We'll eat it.
Disgusting.
This is horrible.
See the crab?
Eating underwater?
Yeah.
You know how it is.
I think I can... No!
Why?
I'm not sticky!
Please!
Ha!
I don't know!
Okay.
Hold the button longer?
How long do I need to hold it?
First person him?
Oh.
Shooting him on the platform.
I don't remember how I did it before, but...
Oh my gosh, the...
The... Oh my gosh.
Getting the camera to work as soon as I'm out of the water is so annoying.
What's this?
Grenades!
Grenades.
Okay.
Ah!
I think I'm gonna just die here because I'm already not feeling this ride.
So, okay.
No!
A bullet!
Hiya!
Uh, that should...
Uh...
Oh,
they got it!
Ewww!
Gonna need some more...
Some more burn away, please.
Maybe I should just stand up on them.
Okay, like, okay.
Oh!
Wait, which one are you?
Uh...
You?
Ah!
I shot the right one!
Wait!
My brothers.
Is he a bee?
I think so.
What?
How did you find me?
How did you find me though?
What was it?
Gosh, okay.
I'm gonna have to figure out what to do.
Grenade!
Did you just kick it back at me?
Idiot!
Wait.
Um...
Return!
Grenade!
The one time I shoot it too far.
No!
Let's go get some food.
Oh yeah, I'll take some fish.
Eat this!
Oh, get up.
Oh, this, this again?
Your little magic trick?
My Hornet!
Doing
his little song and dance again?
Oh my gosh, I cannot see any of this.
This is so annoying.
What's that?
I'm throwing a grenade at you.
Grenade!
Oh!
Uh, don't do that.
Don't do that.
Ah!
Dimey God.
Hey!
Oh, hello, sick.
Oh, where am I actually?
Am I in the middle of nowhere?
I
think I shot and then I shoot again.
I think.
I think I shoot and then shoot again.
Why is the camera angle so bad though?
Oh, that was so close.
8k spray?
Let's try it.
Wait, do I have the 8k on mine?
I don't have to add it to my backpack.
Let's try it.
I can't remember.
Let's just... I'm gonna quit these for now.
Hi from Octoberfest!
Oh my gosh!
No... I'm... I think it's...
What was it?
OG camera?
I can't see anything!
Oh gosh.
I can't see.
I can't even see him.
Stop!
Don't say that!
I'm trying to film!
I'm gonna eat under water again.
You're embarrassing yourself!
Oh, I forgot he said that.
What a jerk!
Crap time!
Hey, this works.
Could this dude be any more known?
Nades and shotgun.
I wonder if the original camera is good here.
Actually...
That was close.
Oh my god!
Hold on!
I love when I just walk up and he's like...
I'm waiting!
No, Tommy gun!
They're gonna be dropping bombs on me.
I keep forgetting to do this insert button here.
What do you mean?
I think he can get me here.
Okay.
There he is!
My brother!
Wait!
No!
There he is!
My brother!
I'm slippery.
It's a little slippery here.
Sorry.
No!
I don't want to just keep shooting.
It doesn't do anything.
I think I just have to wait until he's like...
Is that all you've got?
Until he's...
Take this!
No!
I'm trying!
I'm actually lost.
Hold on.
I'm too close to you.
Smoke?
No!
No, the shotgun doesn't knock the bees off.
I think they absorb it.
I think when he...
When I was doing it...
It was just absorbing it.
I don't think I was missing.
It looked like it was hitting.
Grenades?
But the bees catch the grenades.
So how do I...
Stop them?
Sorry.
This one kills me every time.
It's so funny.
You're like this.
Three shotgun shots to remove.
Ahhh!
You gotta hit him multiple times.
I see.
That's why.
I think it's this one.
Oh!
Wait, what?
Huh?
Phase two time.
No!
Oh my god.
I'm scared of these guys.
Grenade!
Not grenade.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm actually...
Where am I for real?
Oh, he's doing this again.
Hold on.
Hold on, I'm trying to figure out where I can go.
I'm lost.
Ahhh!
Not the...
I was lost!
Hahaha.
Okay, there's our little platform.
I feel comfortable with this one.
Hahaha.
Phew.
There you are.
Okay.
I don't know if that hit him, actually.
Was
that...
Oh, he sent a scent.
Bombs!
Uh oh.
Woo!
Grenade!
Hahaha.
I got him though, didn't I?
Just a little bit.
Where could I be?
Ah!
There he is!
My brother!
I'm hungry.
Hahaha.
Eat a little bit of a reticulated python.
Boss, I'm so happy to see you back!
Thank you!
Thank you for the super time!
Hahaha.
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, oh, oh.
Come out and play!
I'm right here!
Get him!
Where do I aim with this thing?
I got him, but I didn't.
I'm confused.
I think I'm gonna try and only go back and forth between this one and...
Okay, he's that one.
Oh yeah.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is!
Slowly...
coming towards me.
Ah!
Wait, I'm lost.
So I'll go back and forth between these two platforms.
Bernard!
Center mass...
It's so hard, right?
Look at this, at least.
There he is!
My brother!
Pshew!
They're makin' this fi...
Oh, uh...
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Oh wait, I'm...
Okay, I have to stick this one out, I think.
Ah!
Gonna go back to...
Wait.
The other side?
This way.
Okay.
At least they drop.
Lots of bullets still.
For this fight.
Bernard.
Alright, let's go back to the other side.
Slowly but sure, we're chippin' it away!
We're chippin' it away!
You guys...
I'm...
I'm speedrunning.
You see me?
How?
I was under the water.
What the hell was that?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Tommy gun!
Slowly but surely...
Chippin' it away!
Oh.
Sorry, it's so funny that he's, like, shooting over there.
What the?
I didn't...
I didn't know he could do that!
Wait, where's the...
Oh my gosh!
The jump's scaring me for real!
Game is laggin' a little bit.
Hey!
Stop!
Thank ya!
Oh.
Get him!
Hmm...
A bullet.
I thought I was dropping stuff for this one.
I...
was, uh, mistaken.
Guess it's time to use our AK.
Grenade!
That recoil is disgusting.
It's, uh...
You know...
I don't think it's...
I can't tell when they're gonna...
I can't tell if they're gonna, you know...
I have, like, just one more shot on this guy!
No!
Tommy gun!
Can't shoot the armor off with AK.
Oh!
Okay, I thought it would be, like, the shotgun.
So I have to grenade him.
But I can only grenade...
Oh my gosh, this is so frustrating cause I'm at, like, the last bit!
Grenade finisher.
Actually... Wait, can I do it here?
No!
I was wrong!
What's this one?
Kill it!
Oh, it's a grenade.
Just a tiny bit more!
Just a little bit more!
I'm afraid the bees are gonna grab my grenades though.
There he is!
My brother!
I am once again hungry.
This guy is a pain in my butt!
Dammit, this works.
Did I get shotgun?
I don't think so.
No.
I didn't even...
Please...
Aw, see?
They just grab it!
I
think I have to do it while he doesn't notice me.
But, so...
Oh...
Triangle while select equals single shot.
Wait...
Can I see a secret spot?
Nope.
Just kidding.
My eye is deceiving me.
When he grabs it...
Wait, what's...
Wait, maybe?
Maybe, maybe, maybe?
Please?
Yeah!
Okay.
Alright, guys.
We're good to go.
I knew it...
I knew it was giving me more!
I just... didn't know...
Okay.
Yay!
We're so back, baby.
I love the shotgun.
We're so back!
Alright, let's go over here.
Come on.
Come on, Snake.
It's the one on the right.
It's gotta be.
Hello?
Please.
Yay!
Thanks for giving me more shotgun ammo, game!
The pain.
So, if I were to throw the grenade and then shoot it when the bees are all over it, it would explode and then get him?
Is that how it would?
The pain!
It explodes!
These guys ended World War 2?
Could've fooled me!
What?
I think he's a great...
warrior.
I wish it would give me more...
um...
ammo.
I don't think there's anything else around here that I hadn't already gotten.
Really just wanna take my shotgun now and blast through everything.
Why did he explode?
Why did the high explode?
I was gonna call.
The exit from the cave should be toward the back.
Proceed through the cave and find the exit...
Major, you're not gonna comment about my great victory just then?
I literally just offed one of the members of a Cobra unit.
Please!
Give me the credit!
I see you've caught yourself a maroon shark.
A maroon shark?
The maroon shark is found mostly in Southeast Asia.
But it's not actually a shark.
It's related to the carp.
It's also known as the redfin cigar shark, the river barb, and the salton fish.
Why does it have so many names?
How does it taste?
According to the guide, it's good.
But it's kind of oily and has a lot of little bones.
Fine with me.
I never worry about the little things.
So I gathered.
Snake does not worry about the little things.
Wearing the water pattern, are we?
The water pattern was used a lot by the old German defense force.
Even though it's called the water pattern, it wasn't designed specifically to blend in underwater.
Then what?
They only gave it that name because the pattern resembles the waves on the surface of a pool of water.
But still it really does look like it could be confused for liquid waves.
It might conceal you underwater.
I don't...
I don't understand the purpose of this.
Alright, let's get going.
Unless I really don't think there's anything else underneath here.
I think they took away all the items.
So let's just go.
I feel like usually in games I'll like want to use I'll want to go for the non-lethal method.
But in these they explode.
So going non-lethal just doesn't feel right.
And these they just blow up.
Oh in urban areas.
I guess so.
Blue is the most effective color for nighttime operations.
Okay that makes sense.
The reward camo for the pain sucks.
Oh what do you get actually?
Oh.
Congrats on defeating the pain!
Add to slow chip for 2 plus hours the first time I tried for hard and trank.
Whatever it takes to win.
2 plus hours!
Oh it's smoggy.
It's dusty crusty here.
Oh no.
Drones.
People.
People on drones.
Flying people.
People in crafts that should not be available at this time.
The Pokemon glow!
R fruit.
Dang it.
More demon.
What's the R fruit?
You can shoot the bees you gather with this camo.
Wait what?
Really?
I see you found a Russian false mango.
This mango is a mango like fruit found only in Selenoyarsk.
Selenoyarsk.
The egg shaped fruit is sweet and tangy with a pleasing aroma.
Just like a mango.
But it's not.
It's a fake mango.
Also the seeds can be used to make a medicine that aids in digestion.
What?
It might come in handy if you ever have an upset stomach.
If you ever have a tummy ache snake.
Tummy hort.
It's a fake mango.
False mango.
Food for...
Let's eat.
Let's eat!
Not eaten yet.
Said to be edible in a pinch.
I don't know if we...
want that though, right?
Let's throw the vampire bat away.
Actually, let's eat the vampire bat.
I'm gonna puke.
Nice.
Look at these tiny little frog...
Okay, that's a poison frog.
That's a poison frog.
I see you've captured a poison dart frog.
The poison dart frog is native to the tropical rainforests of Central and South America.
I'm gonna eat it.
And then cure myself of my tummy ache.
But for some reason, the ones in that area seem to be much bigger than that.
Ah, it's for the game.
So you can see it on the map.
Pomeleotoxin.
Long ago, people used the poison to coat their arrows for hunting.
Watch out, because if you eat one, you get food poisoning.
It's okay.
If I eat it and then I spin around and throw up, I'll be fine.
Oh wait, my stamina is like full.
I don't know if we can eat it.
We'll hold on to him.
They might get hungry, the guys.
They might be like, oh my gosh, free frog!
And eat it and then die.
That might happen.
In versions of MGS3, with trophies and achievements, you gotta eat the poison now.
Oh, wait.
I don't want this.
Let's save.
You wanna save?
Hold on a sec.
Yeah.
I'm starting to get hungry.
Oh my gosh, it's already been almost four hours.
I wanna get through...
Hmm...
I can't...
This part of the game always...
I can't remember.
I know the fear is next.
Um...
Hey, Snake.
Have you ever seen Forbidden Planet?
Maybe I'll order a pizza.
It's about this expedition that goes to the planet Altair IV in an ultra-fast spaceship.
When they arrive, they meet the survivor of the last expedition, Dr. Morbius.
Dr. Morbius was exploring the planet along with his daughter, Altaira.
There while Robby the robot.
Ignoring the doctors' warnings, The expedition team is suddenly attacked by an invisible creature called the Monster from the Id.
The special effects they use for the science stuff were really neat.
I wish I had a robot like Robby that could make anything I wanted it to.
I'm more interested in that invisible monster.
If I were invisible, I wouldn't have to bother hiding Getting on it.
Invent it.
Morbin, Morbius,  uncle.
I was so busy at the Papa John's that I didn't even notice.
It mentioned more billion dollars.
Let's see, what's over here?
I
didn't even need it.
It's messed up.
That will never not be funny.
You guys are sadists.
Sadists, all of you.
I'm gonna run out of bandages and...
The timing?
What did you say?
Oh Snake, be careful.
There are claymore mines around.
What?
Hold on, I actually do want to order pizza.
I'm ordering pizza menu.
Let's see.
Create your own pizza.
No, no, no.
Customize.
Okay, I'm gonna put on this.
Oh wait, let me see if there's a deal.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I don't want to just order a pizza and it be so expensive.
Is there like a, you know...
View all deals.
Sorry.
Hold on, I'm trying to...
I'm not gonna tell you what I'm gonna put on it.
I'm not gonna tell you.
Free delivery?
Oh.
Yeah, I have to spend a certain amount.
Oh, here we go.
Yay, create your own pizza.
There we go.
I found a deal.
Oh, I'm getting really hungry.
Okay, I might have to have a snack.
You guys might have to have like a little snack break.
Pineapple and green pepper?
No?
Anchovies.
I had anchovies for the first time not too long ago.
And you know what?
I didn't hate it.
Wait, how many can I put on?
How many?
I can't add deal to cart.
I can't remember how many toppings I said I could do.
No, thanks.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Actually, I'm gonna edit it then.
I can get one more.
Yeah,
this should be good.
Update.
I'm like literally...
My mouth is watering.
I'm so hungry.
Oh, I'm so hungry thinking about this.
Wait, why is the total more than...
Okay, hold on.
I think I messed up.
Wait, no, not replace.
Hold on, you guys.
I messed up my order.
Hold on.
Sorry, I'm ordering pizza.
I'm ordering pizza.
If anybody is curious, I'm ordering pizza.
It's pineapple on pizza.
Everyone likes it.
You guys want a slice?
Pineapple on pizza?
Coupon codes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What the...
Oh, yes.
Okay, the coupon worked.
The coupon worked.
Okay.
What the...
Can I just...
Oh, here we go.
You know, I'll do this.
I'm so hungry.
Okay, a tip.
Order.
Log in!
Okay,
I ordered it.
Free pizza is free...
It's not free, but...
That's okay.
Okay.
I need a snack, though.
I need a snack.
I'm sorry, guys.
Can I...
I'm gonna go grab something.
Maybe some crackers.
Real quick.
I'm starting to get all shaky, you know.
Take a break.
Take a break, everyone.
I'll be...
I'll try to be fast.
I'll try to be quick.
Do a Google search for free pizza and Metallica MP3.
What does...
What?
Real survival mode.
Just gonna eat more R fruit.
Yeah, I'm gonna eat R fruit right now.
Peanut butter?
Wait, that's a great idea.
I'm gonna go eat peanut butter.
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna...
Here, I'll leave you with a...
Here we go.
Uniform.
Going with the tea.
And then make it a little bit cursed.
Wait, you can see the top of his head.
Got any bald spots up there?
Oh, hold on.
I can't control this thing.
Oh my gosh, everything's inverted.
Oh, no!
There you go.
I'll be right back.
I'm so sorry.
I'll be like just a few minutes.
Let me...
Let me also put on some like...
Oh, wait.
If I put on music, you won't hear it.
Wait, can I even access my music?
No.
Everything is bad.
Now, just think of that melody and repeat it like 50 times.
Guys.
You will never believe what I found in my cabinet.
You'll never believe.
You'll never believe it is the most appropriate...
Snack for...
For Metal Gear.
Hey!
I got a Calry98.
A R ett It's just...
In my pantry?
That would be so sad.
Can you imagine?
A frog?
That would be horrifying.
I think I would prefer the rat over the frog.
Calorie Mate!
Okay.
It's not what I want, but since pizza's coming, I'll just hold out.
Wait, I forgot to get more drink!
I gotta get more tea.
Yeah, hold on.
Someday...
Okay, it's fruit flavored.
I don't think I've ever tried the fruit flavored one before.
Okay.
I'm gonna try it.
Fruit flavored Calorie Mate.
Tasty!
Wait, oh gosh!
I'm eating this without a drink!
It's so dry!
Can I go get a drink?
Okay.
It says it's fruit flavored, but it's like heavy on the pineapple.
Nom nom.
Alright.
This VTuber is deceased?
What are you talking about?
I'm back.
Let me eat a little bit more Calorie Mate.
How appropriate.
I will put it on my pizza.
Okay.
I'm not wasting more time.
Oh, let's also change?
I'm just like, yeah, I'm coming in as shirtless Raiden.
Let's go.
My stamina bar is high, baby.
I'm good and healthy.
Wait.
Do I have space?
Whoa!
Where is Kero-tan?
Where could he be?
In this area.
Closure room's out.
Back here at the beginning?
Kero-taaaaaaan!
Are you hissing at me?
Oh!
Stay away.
Wait.
Did I go this way?
Oh, that's where I blew up.
That's right.
I'm gonna add the reverb for the, um, you know, the ambiance.
This way.
Oh!
This...
Glow.
Where is Kero-tan?
Hey, Bloco.
Momoko.
Duh.
I give up.
I give up trying to find him.
Oh my gosh.
Into the piss!
Spider-man.
Aww.
Yeah, baby.
It's a good thing we've got our craw cat here.
Hmm.
Hum.
Da-da-da.
Tiger.
Oh.
Water.
That
was so close.
That was so close.
Alright.
Oh my god!
He's right there!
The only guy to ever have worn a craw cat.
Can you think I can knock him off?
But he's wearing a helmet, isn't he?
Bye!
I wanna get that trap grenade.
I don't think the...
Oh, wait.
I have to add it back to my...
Let's see.
I feel that...
The platform will crash and make noise.
Okay, okay.
I feel that the hovercrafts don't make me so like side-eyed just because like you go from this to all the stuff in V and you know, I know V is like 10 years later but...
I don't know.
How is she gonna handle the scene coming up?
I will let him live.
Don't worry.
I'll let him live.
It's just the one way, right?
I thought there was another way over here.
I think.
I thought so, right?
Over here?
Yeah.
So, you know, it's honestly...
And also like Metal Gears in general are just so crazy and everything...
A lot of the tech in this is pretty crazy so I don't mind.
I don't think it's like so...
It doesn't throw me so much out of the game.
You know.
That's all.
Oh my gosh.
Don't just dive like that snake!
It's scaring me.
Maybe I should go back to the other side.
There's nothing really for me to do here.
I don't want to activate anything on this part.
Okay.
We'll go back.
Goofy like the rest of the game.
Yeah, exactly.
SPD is here.
Oh!
Well, let's do this part over here first.
The music is...
Let's do that first.
And then we'll...
Like over here?
And then I can come back.
Here we go!
I love a crocodile!
Speaking from a technological viewpoint, the Shuggle Hut is more possible in current time than the other units.
Maybe, yeah.
I guess so.
The other units are literally like baby Gundam.
So it's funny how like things are so of their time period in the games, but then you just have like some of this crazy technology.
I was one of the guards trying...
Sokolov!
Volgen!
Hot lady.
Oh my god!
Sokolov!
Volgen!
You better not pee your pants, you little baby.
...
Tanya!
That's right.
That's her name.
I couldn't remember her name.
Tanya!
Vol'gin!
Oh my god.
She looks like a little puppet.
Vol'gin, you monster!
Utter booby.
Necklace.
Oh god, it spat everywhere.
They make it so obvious.
Oh my god.
Let's find out just how lucky you are.
I like this part.
Watch closely.
This is Ocelot getting his little, his little grippers in torture, you know?
Starting to realize he kind of likes watching people, you know, tremble a little bit.
One of these three guns has a single bullet in it.
I'm going to pull the trigger six times in a row.
Are you ready?
It's actually pretty good odds though.
Uh, it's, it's in the cup on...
Look at him.
He's like...
Don't pee your pants, little baby.
What did I tell you?
Looks like your luck hasn't run out yet.
No!
You guys, do you realize for...
In terms of the Metal Gear Solid series, that's three for three.
That's crazy.
The boss is so cool.
Yes, mommy.
Almost like a recurring theme.
I think it's like a...
You know how little kids just think that's funny?
Dismantle his gun.
Ooh.
Dummy.
The necklace is... so...
Has the CIA dog been disposed of yet?
The pain is dead.
What?
Uh-oh.
He may be a child.
But he's definitely one of yours.
Ooh.
I'm just that good.
I fear Khrushchev may have a hand in this.
We have no time to lose.
You must eliminate him before the final test.
She's like rolling his eyes.
She's like, okay.
Rolling her eyes.
Oh!
There he is!
The end.
Wake up, old man.
I'm leaving him to you.
The fear.
Ah!
Yah!
Yeah!
He's just being a little freak over there.
Take the shot.
No!
It's no fun.
The old man is always sleeping.
Is he all right?
It's no fun.
If I were playing, like, by myself, I'd do it, probably.
I'd try at least.
Normally, he's dead.
I'm not gonna take the shot.
But he'll wake up when the time is right.
And when he does, it will be the end for the...
The last time I played this, I had actually not such a bad time with the end fight, so I'm curious how it will be for me this time.
I think I lucked out a lot before this one.
It was fun.
Sokolov isn't worth your love.
Oh...
Are you trying to woo me?
You can entertain me until the rain stops.
Volga's not here for love, he's here for a freak.
Oh, yah!
Oh!
Volgan!
Koawah barrah.
Oh...
I feeling the pain.
He's here for the nasty.
He's not here for love.
Maybe he does love them though.
In his own little, weird, sadistic, freaky way.
We don't know.
Just leave this guy sleeping.
Okay, old man.
I'm not gonna kill the end, you guys.
I'm not gonna do it.
I know I can.
Actually, I don't even have a... I don't even have a... like a...
I didn't grab a... like a... a sniper.
Yeah.
But I... I can't...
I don't... I didn't even pick it up in that other area.
But seriously...
Stop yelling at me to do it.
Because that's what I'm doing.
It's not fun to kill him right now.
It's not fun.
Gosh.
Told you the SVD was in the other place.
I know.
And I said I wasn't... I was gonna go back and get it.
I didn't need it.
Because I wasn't gonna kill him!
Gosh.
It's fun if you save and do it.
Yeah, but I didn't even grab it.
I wonder...
Is it time to go back and get it?
He like... he disappears so fast though.
Why you no shoot?
I always fought him.
I don't know why people are so... like... weird about that part in particular.
Like they get so like...
You must...
You must shoot at him or else...
It's...
You know...
Or else...
You're not playing the game.
If you grab the early sniper, you can kill Chen.
People just like using exploits.
Maybe.
Maybe that is why.
Oh wait.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh.
Stop Snake.
I just want you to...
I just want you to be normal for a second.
Besides this guy,
We have...
Oh, it's so hard to tell.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many fish.
There's so many fish, it's hard to tell.
Also, I forgot my backpack.
Please save and wait a week.
Yeah...
Because I didn't kill him here I'm definitely gonna do that.
I'm gonna be like, okay.
Would be awesome.
I'm just gonna... do that instead.
Mark 22... only
7 months to go.
7 months?
What's in 7 months?
Oh that's right, I don't have much left.
I think I might have to kill this guy.
The river runs red.
The river runs red with the blood of the man.
Emery Red!
Emery!
Hello!
Hello, friends.
Hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
I just killed a man, sorry.
If you witnessed that.
If you saw that...
No, you didn't.
Oh my god.
I think that guy's asleep.
No, he's not.
I could put him to sleep forever, though.
I could put him to sleep forever.
I don't know where the third guy is, though.
Oh shoot.
Self-defense?
I'm just a gator.
I'm just a... I'm not even a gator.
I'm just a crocodile.
Is there even another guy?
I thought there was.
I thought there were three.
The motion detector is impossible.
In these areas.
I don't even remember where the thing is.
Kero-tan!
We found him, though.
Is it...
Just a croc.
Yeah, just a croc.
I mean, crocs?
Like they said, the crocs are dangerous.
They're out for blood.
What I put on the cap?
You guys, it just makes me... technically a pacifist run, because no it isn't.
When I put on the cap, it just makes me wild.
I can't help it.
It makes me wild!
Looking around for items.
You understand, right guys?
You understand?
It's not my fault.
It's the cap.
The cap... oh!
Oops.
The croc cap changes people.
Exactly.
I want to go in there.
Did I kill everybody here?
What the hell is that?
Squash.
Ah!
It poisoned me!
I wanted to squish it!
Oh wait, I need the serum.
Wait, do I need the antidote?
Oh yeah.
What's the difference between serum and antidote?
Oh, this is food poisoning!
Oops.
Poison spider.
Yes!
Well, if there was any chance of him being alive...
Wait, where did he... oh, there it is.
Okay.
I don't need it.
I'm hungry.
Now no one will ever find him.
Yeah, the fish... I'm feeding the fish pretty much.
Let's eat a maroon shark!
Oh no, this is not the bloco.
Let's eat the crab.
Hey, this works.
Let's get back up there.
I hate how slowly he walks in the water.
What is... okay, is it behind the door?
I feel like I'm crazy.
Excuse me.
I'm coming to grab your stuff.
If I blow this up...
Can I blow this up?
SVD.
If I blow this up, does this count as like an armory?
Yeah?
It's a square.
Bonne joie!
All right, we got it.
Perfect.
Crockett.
Nobody will ever know.
Mystery.
Hello?
Can I get out of here?
There we go.
Now dive, snake.
Dive!
The sound when you run on the dock is so satisfying.
It's pretty nice.
It's like a nice...
This sound, however.
I'm gonna save real quick.
Quick.
Yeah, save.
Nice.
This is the original PS.
Not the original, it's subsistence, but it is on my PS2.
The spider?
A giant monster.
They bring it into the city in a state of hibernation, but it wakes up and starts wrecking the place.
So why did the spider turn huge?
Look at the membership, thank you!
I told you, it suddenly mutated.
I can't tell if it's...
Yeah, right.
Snake, it's people like you that take all the fun out of watching movies.
Always nitpicking and taking things too seriously.
Honestly, why even bother?
Look, the important thing isn't that it got big.
Then what is important?
The fact that there's a huge spider destroying everything.
I think it's pretty important that it got big.
Okay.
You think that end is still there?
You think he's still chillin' out there?
You think he's still there?
You think he's chillin'?
You think he's still asleep?
You think people forgot about him?
They just didn't bring him back inside?
He's out of there?
Oh my god!
How will it work?
In the water?
Wait, how does this work actually?
Oh, L1.
There's three guys.
I could blow that up.
And blow them up.
What if I blew them up?
What if I just blow them all up?
Hmm...
.
Come in, HQ.
This is HQ.
Signs
of enemy infiltration.
Commence alert formation.
Acknowledge all sending reinforcements.
Aw, damn.
.
What's wrong?
Hmm?
.
Nah, I'm just a crocodile.
Guys, I'm just a crocodile.
.
I'm just a croc.
I'm just a crocodile.
.
I'm just a croc.
Oh, they're gonna replace these guys.
They're kinda silly, aren't they?
.
Unless...
I take them out.
.
Oops.
How did that not hit?
.
I'm just a crocodile.
You can't swim, can you?
.
What's wrong?
Croc with a sniper.
.
Get his leg.
How can you hold this up still?
.
You're so brave.
I'm just a crocodile.
.
Just a crocodile.
I'm a lark.
They're gonna send new people in.
.
Might as well play with my food.
Look at this poor guy.
.
Problem solved.
Maybe.
.
Okay.
I'll do my best not to kill anyone else.
.
It was because...
You know...
.
They just...
Wiggle, wiggle.
.
Crocodiles are violent.
Have you never seen the crocodile death roll?
It's kind of insane, actually.
This is so terrible looking.
Jerry!
Thanks for the 20 gifts and thank you!
It's because I was so nervous.
I really would have drank them, but I was...
nervous about my... suppressor.
I didn't want to waste it.
Especially if I could just kill these guys as a crocodile.
You should give the croc a name.
What should his name be?
Malcolm?
Malcolm the bloodthirsty crocodile?
I just realized the wall where... where... oh my gosh.
Please.
Where Vulcan smashed it.
It's all smashed up.
That's so cool.
Is there anything in the water?
Like any suppressors?
Any suppressors in the water?
Mintai, hi!
I'll take that.
Yeah, baby.
Careful with the croc hat.
I hear it subsistence add an extra boss if you wear it for the majority of the game.
Crocodile Dundee!
Kind of worth, actually.
I would wear it the whole game if I could see Crocodile Dundee.
Wait a second.
What's over here?
This is not where I came from.
Is it?
Maybe it is where I... no.
Oh, that is where I came from.
Just kidding.
Oh.
Okay, let's continue onwards.
How do I... can I grab here?
Can I lift up?
Yeah, please.
Okay.
Wait, I wanted to grab his body.
I already grabbed his body.
It's inside the warehouse.
Thank you, wuss.
I don't think I can have my croc hat anymore.
So sad.
We'll do splitter.
I haven't done that one, I think, this whole time.
And we'll go...
We'll go naked.
Animals.
Wowee.
Where is my pizza?
Hold on.
I'm checking on my pizza.
Where's my pizza?
They said it was not gonna take this long.
Driver ate the pizza.
If he did, I will seriously cry.
Okay.
It should be soon.
Maybe in like the next five minutes.
Hopefully.
Maybe it's bad traffic.
The crocodile got it.
Ahem.
Pizza guy is watching the stream?
I sure hope.
This is where I first threw up.
Let's do it again.
Spin.
That's nasty.
Dang.
That's gross.
Maybe black was not the best camel.
Maybe...
Tiger stripe.
You're about to be death rolled by a crocodile.
Just use the strength that you get from your...
Stop.
Someone's hungry.
And it's me.
That actually wasn't his stomach.
That was mine.
Well, I should have grabbed some more fish while I was in the water, huh?
I guess I could go back if I needed to.
Let's see.
Little baby.
Where else are your friends?
I can't remember where these guys are at.
I see them over there.
Anybody else?
Just some rats?
What was that noise?
Just some rats maybe?
Anybody else up?
Oh, there he is.
Why doesn't it show me that on the radar?
So rude.
Where can I get him from?
Might be tight.
Get up there!
Where did he go?
There he is.
I see him.
He's moving across there.
Right there.
Yippee!
Is that all of them?
I'll take that.
Desert face.
Think there's more?
Is there?
Clean.
Oh, crab!
I guess I won't be so willy-nilly then.
I'll be a little more sneaky.
A little more strategic.
Perhaps.
Grab your body.
And take what you have.
Nice.
Rob you for all that you're worth.
If there's any other guys, maybe I can seek you soon.
I thought I heard footsteps.
But maybe not.
I think we're okay.
Disinfect.
Can I go in here?
I can.
Oh yeah!
We got some ramen noodles!
Wait.
I can blow this up.
I can blow this place up.
Box on the box?
Oh, thank you!
Did I put the TNT in there or am I crazy?
Use your hands!
Use your arms, Snake!
Just use your arms!
I know they're like a little T-Rex, but please.
Oh, I have to hang and get it.
Shoot.
Thanks for the Zip-A-Tot!
Never learned how to crouch walk.
Yeah, that's definitely why.
For real.
Yippee!
Wait a second.
He only had two.
I don't want him waking up.
This suppressor respawns?
No way.
Okay, let's put down a TNT here.
And again, once I...
Before I leave, we'll blow it up.
Burn the food.
All right.
Very good, everybody.
Okay, I don't see anybody there.
Gimme!
Nice.
Is there anything else that I missed down here?
I don't think so.
I think it was just the suppressor that I got.
Right?
I...
think so.
Hmm.
You're in the clear.
Sorry for the false alarm.
No!
You're all good.
No worries at all.
What was it?
Circle.
And they'll never eat again.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna try this again.
Yibby!
My pizza!
I'll be right back.
Pizza time!
Pizza time.
BRB.
Sorry.
I know I've been, like, leaving so much this stream.
BRB, though.
Actually, I'm gonna change it.
Pizza time.
Pizza time!
Finally, pizza.
I wonder if it was outside my door for a while.
It's kind of cold, but it did take a while.
Yay, pizza!
A little break time.
Break time for pizza.
How are you guys doing?
How was your weekend?
Did you guys do anything fun?
Did you guys do anything?
I know some people are at TwitchCon.
I went
golfing.
Wow.
I got a golfer.
How's the pizza?
It's so good.
You went to the haunted house?
A haunted house?
Like my place?
What are the toppings?
It's pineapple and green pepper.
Exactly what I like.
I cut down a tree.
Oh my god.
Gosh, I've been like, just thinking about this pizza for the past 30 minutes.
Just wanting this pizza.
But I don't want to spend so much time eating.
So I took a couple bites.
And we continue onward.
...
Pizza Gamer.
We don't fight him just yet.
The fear.
I know you want me to shut up about the thermal goggles, but they might help you see things in this area.
...
Like that guy?
Or that?
What is that?
Is that a guy?
What is that against a wall?
What is that thing?
...
What is that?
The goggles!
It doesn't even show up.
There's snakes.
There's lots of things in the trees.
...
There's pixels?
Oh, I think it's a rock.
...
I think actually it's a rock.
This is a place that I wish I could crouch walk, you know?
...
What's up there?
That's a trap!
That up there is a trap for sure.
Oh, don't eat that.
Don't eat that frog.
...
I remember.
Don't eat that frog.
Wait, can't I get this?
For like him to eat?
Won't he eat it?
Or am I crazy?
Won't the fear eat frogs?
...
Oh, my bad.
I see that string!
Blabocos!
We gotta get them!
Well, didn't they taste bad though?
...
Maybe I shouldn't get them.
Maybe I shouldn't torture snake.
...
Mococos!
No!
...
What is that?
It's
a bush.
...
Hmm...
I know I need to...
I'm running out of food though.
...
Should probably get this guy, right?
A little snack.
...
Sorry, guy.
You're our snack.
...
Where'd he go?
Okay, there.
...
Is there any way to disable some of these traps?
Like, what does this one over here do?
...
Can an animal set it off even?
Snack!
...
That's a meal.
You got the snake.
Don't let it, don't let it...
It's more afraid of you than you are of it.
...
Like,
what does this one do?
...
Sokolov!
Just kidding.
...
I'm out.
I'm full of food.
...
See any ghosts?
Oh, I forgot the out!
...
Oh, I forgot the...
While we do Codex, I can eat.
We'll do Codex and I'll eat.
Speaking of which... Yeah?
Are you going to eat that?
I was planning on it, yeah.
Well, alright.
Is there some reason I shouldn't?
No, that's not what I meant.
Then what did you mean?
I was just going to say that if you weren't going to eat it, you should bring it back to me.
I've always wanted to try some.
Whatever.
I see you've caught a European rabbit.
A European rabbit is said to have come from the Mediterranean region originally, but nowadays they're found all over the world.
They've been used since ancient times as a source of food, so it might be worth catching them.
Rabbits are known to eat their own excrement.
They eat their own?
That's right.
It's called cecal feces.
When the rabbit eats fiber, the fiber is fermented in the rabbit's appendix, or cecum, and turned into a nutritious substance full of vitamins.
The rabbit excretes the substance and then eats it.
And eats it again to absorb the nutrients.
That's a neat trick.
I think I'll give it a try.
Snake, rabbits and humans don't work the...
I'm just kidding.
You really thought I was going to eat it?
A little, yeah.
Even I wouldn't do that.
I guess not.
But how did those cecal feces taste?
What?
I'm just kidding.
Oh...
Sorry, I was muted so I could chew without fear of being heard.
What?
This guy just...
This guy...
You was not kidding.
Poop eater.
What does it... what's the trap though?
If I hit these trees...
Will I get the mococos?
Nope.
What about up here?
Oh, I see that trap right there.
I see it.
What does it activate?
I don't understand.
Does it just explode?
Oh, here we go.
Thank you.
That looks like a trap too.
I have to be extra careful.
Anything else?
Ribbit.
Why are there so many traps?
Eva!
That's fucking mad.
Oh, she's busy with Vulcan.
That's right.
Zero.
Snake, watch out.
It seems that forest is rigged with a number of traps.
Yeah.
Most of the traps seem to be triggered by tripping a rope stretched across the ground.
What?
Don't just run around like a fool.
Keep an eye on the ground and watch where you step.
Some ropes may be placed so they're hidden in the vegetation.
Be extra careful when you're cutting through the underbrush.
Okay.
If you use the directional buttons to move around stalking, you should be able to spot the traps before you step on them.
Stalking?
Use stalking to move safely through suspicious-looking areas.
Okay.
I'm stalking.
I see a suspicious rope.
And I see a snake.
That could also be a rope.
This guy right here.
There's a squirrel climbing next to him.
He's dead and you're just gonna climb on his body?
Guys, he's just hanging out.
Where's the little squirrel?
Where is it?
Where'd the squirrel go?
Oh god.
I don't remember there being any guys here.
I think it's just traps for now.
Oh gosh, that scared me.
Okay, I'm stalking.
But I wanna get food too.
Wait, I'm all full on food.
Guess I should get rid of some stuff.
I'm not gonna...
I'm stalking.
I see the rope in front of me.
I'm gonna climb under the rope.
There's traps here.
I'm stalking.
Okay.
I see...
I see this one.
Oh my gosh.
Did you see the spikes just...
Oh!
Oh.
I'm stalking.
I don't see any others.
Oh my god.
How many scientists were sacrificed?
Ow!
Oh my god.
Just giving that log a big ol' hug.
Why is there one all the way over there?
Is there stuff out there?
Stop it game.
You're making me want to explore.
Game?
Stop it game.
That looks like a trap right there.
Is it not?
This thing right here?
That's a trap.
I think I'm just gonna leave.
I got lots of food.
The Gorky Labs.
Wait.
What?
I'm gonna leave.
Can't I dress up here?
Or I have to get inside first.
I guess.
I'mma leave.
Oh wait.
I'm all in all black.
Tracer responsible for 200 scientists deaths.
Oh my gosh.
Bye.
There he goes.
Thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is your wallet okay?
You've sent so many today.
Oh my gosh.
I gotta get inside first.
There is a little hole somewhere.
Oh my gosh.
The dogs.
Guys, I hate the dogs.
Oh my god.
Please.
Shoot.
Sticky.
Is that dog laying down?
On the job?
Why isn't it?
Okay.
Hold on.
What's wrong with my controller?
Why isn't it shooting?
I'm a little concerned.
Wait.
I think that's...
I can't tell if there's something there blocking him.
Isn't it like towards the end of the way that the entrance is at?
Guess we'll figure it out.
Huh?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my gosh.
Really?
To stop right there?
I'm not gonna be able to get you through there.
Please.
Turn around.
Or, I mean...
There's nothing here.
What?
Oh.
The dog is just asleep.
Of course.
The dog is just taking a nap.
Okay.
I'm gonna take a nap.
Oh, my gosh.
Please, sir.
Oh!
Oh, my gosh.
Dog.
The dog is awake.
Am I excited for the remake?
Yes, I am.
Very excited.
Wait.
If I pretend to be a crow, I'm not.
He's a crocodile.
He won't care, right?
I have zero stealth.
What?
But it's like dark out.
How do I have zero stealth?
I'm so stealthy right now!
Works every time.
It's like right here, right?
Red and black!
Friend of Jack.
We're all good.
Anything around here?
Yes!
Master Collection just added Steam rewards.
Oh, I did see that!
Yeah, I did.
Which I...
I actually have to re-buy the Master Collection because it's on another account that I...
To get them.
It's on another account that I...
Have, so I have to...
Buy it again.
Which is fine.
Obviously.
But I've already bought it like maybe...
Like seven...
Seven...
Seven times or something.
I don't know.
So...
Kind of fun.
Have to buy it again.
That's right!
Oh...
We have to get...
The door is locked.
What was it?
Um...
Snake, the enemy appears to be using that door to enter and exit the lab.
Yeah.
Think you can sneak in?
Well...
I can't open the door.
That door appears to be locked from the inside.
You won't be able to open it from the outside.
Okay.
But there must be some way to use the door to sneak inside.
And what do you propose?
Time to talk!
Well, I...
How about if you stand in front of the door and perform a ritual dance?
Paramedic is so stupid.
That's what they do in Japan when they find a door that won't open.
Are you serious?
Of course.
He certainly seems to know a lot about Japan.
Yeah, but this is the Soviet Union.
I don't think doing a dance is gonna make the door open.
The way she says it so matter-of-factly...
She says it with such gusto like...
How about you stand outside the door and perform a ritual dance?
Like...
It's so funny!
You say there are attack dogs?
Yeah.
Those attack dogs are Great Danes.
The breed is originally from Germany.
They've been used for hundreds of years as hunting dogs.
Wow.
As you can see, they're very large.
Strong, too.
They've got a calm yet courageous temperament.
And on top of that, they're extremely intelligent.
Well, they're pretty mean to me.
In some cases, a trained Great Dane can be more dangerous than a human opponent.
Watch out for them.
Interesting.
Forget it, Snake.
Forget what?
You were thinking about how they taste, weren't you?
I wasn't thinking.
Don't lie to me.
I could tell by the look on your face.
I wasn't thinking.
You can't see my face.
No, but I can imagine it.
Don't you dare think about trying to capture an attack dog.
You hear me?
Yeah, yeah.
Snake!
What?
His grumbles.
Snake!
All he thinks...
Oh my gosh.
If Solid Snake had heard him, he would be so mad.
If Solid Snake had heard this whole conversation, he would be so mad.
Solid Snake loves dogs.
I mean, it's not a husky, but still.
Snake, be careful of those attack dogs.
Don't worry.
I know how dangerous they are.
Oh, we get another thing about the dogs.
No, you're the one who's dangerous.
Me?
Those dogs are just innocent animals, even if they've been trained to kill.
You shouldn't hurt them unless you have to.
What?
You know, humans and dogs have been living together for 50,000 years, ever since the Stone Age.
Sure, they make good pets and watch dogs, but they also help us out in a variety of different fields.
Not just as police and army dogs, but as hunters, shepherds, rescuers, and seeing-eye dogs.
They deserve our respect.
I know what you mean.
I'm a dog sled, better than you.
I'm a dog sled fan myself.
In the future, many of the jobs that dogs do now will probably be taken over by machines.
They'll have miniature unmanned reconnaissance vehicle and security systems.
No AI.
And in the 21st century, I'll bet they'll even be selling robot dogs as pets.
You've got to be kidding.
But even if that happens, dogs will still be our most trusted companions.
You said dog sled, man.
Unmanned recon vehicle.
That's a pretty scary thought.
Well, for now, trained dogs are the best they've got.
I'm a dog sled.
Is that where he learned?
You think?
Thank you.
Great security.
Absolutely.
I am going to save.
Save.
I haven't seen anything from this game, but it's way funnier than I thought it would be.
That's the thing about Metal Gear.
People think it's just like some crazy...
Some crazy like...
What's the word?
Like...
Army...
Whatever game.
But it actually has so much character.
It's so funny.
Uh oh.
I'm the one that knocks.
So let's take out all the recessive genes.
That means dog sledding is a recessive genetic trait.
Give me a second.
I'm going to restart my PS2.
Ah!
Oh shit.
Let's see.
It might have saved.
We'll see.
Because that's how it was before.
It might have saved.
Let's see.
Perform a ritual dance.
Yeah.
We'll perform a ritual dance in front of my PS2.
I hope it saved.
I hope it's saved.
Let's see.
I'm nervous.
Fingies crossed, everybody.
Fingies crossed.
I would love to listen, but...
We're on a mission.
Hello everybody!
And welcome back to Metal Gear Solid 3 Subsistence.
Oh my gosh.
Starting nice and early today on this Sunday afternoon.
Here we go.
Moment of truth.
Is this the one?
Let's see.
Maybe I should have waited longer.
Maybe that's why it worked before because I waited a long time before I like...
Because I was like, maybe.
Wait,
did I get the...
Oh my gosh.
No!
It took us back so far!
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Okay, we did get it.
Okay.
We're just gonna do exactly what we did before.
I'm gonna kill everybody.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I'm debating whether to end stream.
I didn't want to finish so early.
I wanted to really get past the fear.
Micmac, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Uh...
Woah, woah, woah.
Woah, woah.
I'm not doing that, you guys!
Woah, woah, woah, woah.
My controller is drifting!
Woah, woah, woah.
Okay, I'm ending the stream today.
My controller is...
What's happening?
Oh my gosh.
Why is it doing that?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, Psycho Mantis is real.
What is happening?
Unplug it, plug it back in.
Yeah, let's try that.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, that freaked me out so bad!
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay, everybody.
That was freaky.
That was so freaky.
It's like it's really telling me to...
To quit.
It's really telling me to quit, huh?
Let's just do the same thing.
I did before.
Oh,
I got his...
Oh, dang it.
No!
What's wrong?
Nice radio shot.
Thank you.
Oh, dang it.
I'm gonna get your leggy.
Actually...
I got you in the butt!
Alrighty.
Evil!
You guys, we have to speedrun!
Waka waka.
It's the Croc hat, everybody.
Remember.
Remember, Crock Hat does make you do cruel, cruel things.
Cruel, cruel, cruel things.
The strats are blowing my mind.
What do you mean?
Oh, because I blew them up?
I get it.
I just feel bad.
I feel bad that I have to repeat so much.
And I had such a clean entrance into the facility.
So unfair.
Where did that guy go, anyway?
Oh, there's some stuff down there.
I know it's not my fault, but it just makes me feel bad, anyway.
Just makes me feel bad.
Feels bad, man.
You know.
What was that?
Wait, where did it go?
It disappeared.
It went bloop and left.
Where did it go?
What?
That was weird.
Hopefully, I can do this one just as cleanly.
This room is really not that difficult, though.
It ain't so bad, I guess.
Was there...
There's another suppressor in here and then we'll have...
I'll give it this way.
More MGS3 to play.
Yippee!
Yeah, I'm gonna get a second one.
Okay.
Yeah, the suppressor's in here.
Yes, yes.
I just have to do it perfectly or else I'm like, oof.
Or else...
Or else... it's not so good.
Where are you guys?
Oh, there you are.
Okay, we're gonna wait for him to come over here because he gets blocked by the boxes and I can take him out with no one noticing.
Like, right about...
Right about...
Where you're standing.
Yeah.
And then we scoots our butts over here.
We scoots our butts over here.
And no one notices us.
Okay, there's our other guy.
Where's the other guy?
Where's our upstairs friend?
Oh, there he is.
And I'm gonna go here and crouch.
And up.
Oop.
Yep.
And...
Actually, I'm gonna...
Mm...
I will wait.
I'm gonna wait.
I will wait until he gets closer.
I'm gonna wait until he actually gets up there.
Lined up just for his grave, I know.
Might take a second though.
I don't trust my aim so far.
That's why I'm waiting for him to get closer.
Ha!
Might help if I have it equipped.
Please!
There we go.
Goodness gracious.
Alright!
Recollect everything that I lost.
Please.
Dang,
Minto.
I'm telling you.
Sometimes I just gotta get a microphone.
I gotta get a little move.
I gotta get a little boogie in me.
That's why I never pick my nose.
I always got a little boogie in me.
She's in the zone.
Oh, and we gotta...
So nicely blow up there.
Wait.
There we go.
Here.
Okay.
La la la.
Leave.
Leave this place.
Good one, dad.
Thanks.
That should be everything in this room.
I believe.
Alright.
I missed this part of the stream, so this is an absolute win.
Oh, lucky you.
I will...
Let's see.
Let's eat.
We'll grab something.
This works.
Okay.
Alright.
Now I just gotta be careful of traps.
And...
Oh.
What was this stuff up there?
Was it anything that I could take?
Actually, I honestly can't even remember.
Like, I see the little floaty box up there.
I can't remember if it was something that I even was able to get.
No, I shot down a snake.
I shot down that guy.
I went up here...
Yeah, I went up here for a snake.
I can't remember.
Be careful of traps.
Oh, what's that over there?
I never noticed that spinny thing.
What is that?
Okay, hold on.
I'm not gonna get caught.
You guys?
Okay.
Oh, I'm in the quicksand.
Oh, ow!
I'm getting kissed here?
In the quicksand?
That was close.
That was actually kinda close, wasn't it?
What is this?
I got chewed.
I got a snake.
What is this?
What is that part right there?
That looks like a trap, right?
Yeah, that must be a trap.
Is this a dirty magazine?
Oh my god!
Worth?
Probably.
Okay.
Actually worth.
What I'm gonna do is knock on the door and then leave the magazine.
And then he'll be like, Whoa!
Magazine!
He'll be like, Oh my gosh!
That squirrel scared me!
Oh, what did I just kill?
Accidental death?
Involuntary manslaughter.
My bad.
Okay, I think I'm just gonna keep on going.
Yeah, let's just go.
Am I going in the right direction?
Look for the dead scientists.
They'll guide your way.
Oh!
Wait a second.
Give me the blocos!
Okay, see that?
I'm stalking.
Am I going the right way?
Oh!
That's a trap.
I thought that was a squirrel.
That's a rabbit.
Not a trap.
No!
Rabbit!
Don't go to the trap!
Wait, there's another book.
Should I get it?
Do you think this is a trap?
Two for one deal.
Oh, it's food.
Oh, it's ramen!
Thought it was a book.
Eat all my crabs.
This works.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm a little lost.
Oh, wait!
Kera-tan!
This is the guy that's hugging the tree.
So we go this way.
I know where we are.
I'm not lost.
Can I cut him down?
You think?
Thank you!
Chu gacha?
Oh, you can't hear it.
But it was your simp.
Sorry, Ashes.
Thank you!
Chu!
There you go.
I'll just put it up there.
It meant nothing because it wasn't earned from doing a poll.
But that's okay.
It was a pity one.
A pity Chu.
Poor scientists.
The Gorky Lab.
Gosh, the sound effect sounds so...
There you go.
Like, realistic sometimes.
Like, that sounds like a real bird.
You know?
There we go.
Sometimes it takes me a second.
Where's the dog?
There he is.
Oh, did he notice?
Okay.
Save check.
I don't want to...
Maybe I should do it here, actually.
Maybe I should save here instead of inside.
Maybe inside is like a cursed place, right?
So maybe I should do it here.
Gonna do a new file.
Everybody...
Can't use file 4.
Use a different memory card.
Wait, why?
4 is cursed?
For real?
Uh-oh.
No, it's not full.
Overwrite 1?
Maybe...
I'm afraid of...
Yeah, this one is 6 hours ago.
So...
Or not 6 hours ago, you know.
Snake, have you ever seen On the Beach?
No.
Don't know it.
It's about the survivors of the Third World War.
The entire Northern Hemisphere is obliterated in the nuclear holocaust.
And it's only a matter of time before the few survivors left in the Southern Hemisphere are poisoned by the deadly fallout.
Their only hope is an American nuclear submarine that escapes to the Southern Hemisphere.
They set out for the Arctic to investigate the fallout.
The movie came out in 59.
And the year that the war was supposed to happen was 1964.
In other words, this year.
Nice warning.
Let's hope it stays just a movie.
Oh, I thought you would talk some more.
Hold on.
You got some instant noodles, huh?
Instant noodles?
Uh-huh.
It was invented in Japan just recently.
Add some hot water and it's ready to eat.
It's cheap and can be eaten.
It can be stored for a long time.
And besides, it's delicious.
We got this one earlier.
It's like a miracle food.
Wow.
Tell me something different.
Actually, Sagan, we haven't talked to you in a while.
Looks like you're using splitter face paint.
Splitter is an indoor face paint.
Painting your face with splitter should help you blend in better when you're infiltrating a building.
Ah.
Whoa.
Hold on.
All I got was two slices of pizza, you guys.
Paramag, please.
Save me.
When you're bitten by a venomous animal such as a snake or a spider or hit by a poisoned arrow...
A poisoned arrow?
Your life will decrease with each passing minute, so cure the poison as soon as possible.
To cure poison, go into cure in the survival viewer and inject yourself with a dose of serum.
I don't need like a tutorial.
Kodak, where's the good stuff?
Sokolov is inside the lab.
Look for a way in and use it to infiltrate the lab.
That's it?
Come on, you guys.
I thought there was supposed to be like infinite words.
Clearly this game doesn't want me to eat.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you for the life gift.
Oh my god.
Is your name A?
A?
I can't tell.
Thank you.
Uh oh, I hear a snake hissing at me.
Stop hissing at me.
I'm leaving.
Oh my god.
Snake is gonna get me killed.
My stomach's gonna get me killed.
These guys have been leeched of good topics.
Wait, do I still have a leech?
Oopsie.
What if I wanted him there?
I
wanted him there.
Maroon shark.
So funny.
So, so funny.
This is a friend.
Oh yeah, there is this little hole right here, isn't there?
Maybe I'll go in through here.
We did the door last time.
Whatcha munchin' on?
Pizza.
There's definitely not a crawling entrance in the grass on this side of the complex.
No, I knew this one.
I knew it.
Last time.
Yeah, my save corrupted and I had to, you know...
I almost forgot, but I didn't.
Hello?
How did he not notice that?
But going through the door is kind of fun because you get the little guy who's just like...
Who's knocking?
It's fun, you know?
I had it!
Pressure.
Please.
Please, I have you.
Just take the shot!
Snake!
Oh my gosh.
Take the shot!
Golly!
I think there's one...
Maybe?
There we go.
No, I can't do it.
You guys don't realize how often I quote Metal Gear stuff.
And how often I quote that in the game.
In particular.
I'll just be like...
No, I can't do it.
Oh, that's right!
And we can blow this one up too.
TNT!
What is this?
Wait, what is this?
What is it?
What is this?
But going inside the building...
Does it lead to...
Maybe it does.
Oh, M16 prototype.
Oh...
I know I need to go in through that door.
I'm just...
Perusing.
You know?
I'm taking a little gander around the area.
Is this one...
Oh, we'll take that.
Just kidding.
I'm full.
See guys, I always have too many bullets.
I just don't...
I'm too...
I'm too passive at this game.
Actually, isn't there a way down here as well?
Or am I crazy?
Claymore.
Time to...
Oh no!
I forgot the TNT.
Should I go back and do it?
Should I go back?
I'm gonna go do it.
I'm gonna go...
Wait, what if it's still there.
What if it's...
What if it's still there?
What is it?
Damn it.
These guys only have two.
I think I can do it in time, but you know...
I'm just a...
Just for safe measure.
I'm.
Do, do, do...
TNT.
Okay.
I'm gonna blow it up.
I'm gonna blow it all to hell.
I'm gonna blow it all to hell!
Where's the orange entrance?
Okay.
Negotiate.
This feels so familiar, doesn't it?
Wait a second.
This is the... this is like the one that's Kabuki style, isn't it?
Kabuki's female role face paint.
What if I look like that with my, um...
With my... scientist outfit on?
Call Sigint?
Oh yeah, let's see what he says.
Sigint, look at this.
I'm beautiful.
It's called Oyama.
Oyama?
Yeah.
It's the name of an androgynous Japanese deity.
Are you serious?
From who?
Paramedic.
Never mind.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the 50!
In any case, that face paint doesn't seem to work very well.
Your camo index is way down.
Unless you want the enemy to see you, I'd change to something else.
Oh.
Okay.
Let me guess.
You were just getting to like it.
It kinda grew on me.
Fine.
Get yourself shot.
He likes it.
Alright guys, time to be a scientist.
But also to like...
Okay, if I take down the other scientist...
What?
What do you mean, huh?
All I did was crawl out!
Is it the face paint?
Oh.
I'm a scientist!
With splitter face paint!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, the rat.
Is he coming out?
Look at this rat!
He wants to talk to me!
Okay, never mind.
Hold on, I must...
Wait, let me get rid of the face paint.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh my gosh, look how...
Glasses!
What a hands...
He looks so good!
I'm not even a glasses person that much, but man...
He looks...
He looks too good in the glasses!
He looks so good.
Oh my god, he's got his own name tag too.
I know, it's so cute.
Oh.
Hi.
Right.
Why are you staring out the window, you freak?
Do your job!
Do your work!
I see you're disguised as a scientist.
It suits you rather nicely.
Yeah, I know.
As long as you don't do anything suspicious like roll or crawl...
I definitely crawled.
...the enemy should have no reason to suspect you.
Sokolov is somewhere inside that lab.
Okay.
Find out where he is and make contact with him.
If you want to know where Sokolov is, why don't you ask one of the people around there?
Wait, how do you a...
Oh, like, do I hold them up with a knife?
I don't think they'd like that, though.
Some types of food spoil faster than others.
Animal and fish meat goes bad relatively fast, but plants and mushrooms generally last a little longer.
Animals won't go bad if you capture them alive, though.
You can tell whether food has gone bad or not by looking closely at the icon on the food screen.
Instead of, you must be Ames.
Where is Sokolov?
So be sure to check the icon before you eat the food.
Thanks, paramedic!
I'm afraid to save, you guys.
I'm so afraid to save every... I'm so afraid to save.
Wondering if I should, like, save and then...
I have another memory card, I just have to find it.
Just reuse 1, 2, 3.
You wanna save?
Hold on a sec.
Yeah, I might have to save frequently.
It's gonna interrupt my score, but it's not my fault!
It's... or my... what's it called, you know?
It's not my fault, though!
I just... I have to do...
I have to do it.
Okay.
Okay, I think I'm... I think I'm gonna...
I think I might actually... stop here.
Oh no!
I wanted to get to the...
Okay.
I have to find it.
Why is it... why is every...
Why is every Metal Gear...
...MGS3 stream ending so cursed?
Actually, what if I, like, unplug it and plug it back in?
No.
I'm scared.
I'm just gonna go find the other one.
I don't know.
I don't know, because I don't wanna take up all my save slots.
You thought it was Liquid who was your biggest fan, but it was always me!
Seroto.
I live on through these sunglasses.
Like them?
You did...
No, I didn't blow on it!
I didn't blow on it.
Try overwriting four.
Best bet would be another card in the slot, too.
Yeah.
I will do.
I would go look for it now, I just don't know where it is, so...
I don't know how long it would take me.
I have to... I have some...
I have, like, five drawers I need to search through.
Man...
It's so annoying because it, like, says it saves, but it doesn't.
And so that's what I'm scared of the most.
Right now, one and three are our only working save slots.
Which scares me a lot.
You know?
So...
I could try three.
Let me try three.
If it saves, I'll keep going.
And if not, then I'll...
Let's see.
Okay.
Alright, let's keep going.
Snake, have you ever seen the War of the Worlds?
No.
These flying saucers from Mars arrive on Earth this morning.
The sky is as meteorites.
The saucers use their heat rays to attack the nearby towns.
And then...
And then?
Um...
Yeah?
Something wrong?
Uh, the thing is, I was too scared to watch.
I had my eyes shut almost the whole time.
Then you haven't seen it.
No, it's not that.
It's...
Just use one and three.
We're losing a lot of slots.
You haven't seen that, have you?
We're losing slots.
That does remind me, though.
When I was two years old, my father listened to the radio drama, and he said, I'm a version of the story.
It was right after dinner on Sunday, and we were relaxing in the living room.
They said monsters had come out of a meteorite that landed in New Jersey.
Oh my god.
What if you were in New Jersey?
You would obviously know that it's fake.
My father said he and my older brother actually believed it and started yelling and panting.
You would be like, what meteorite?
Where did a meteorite land?
My mother supposedly grabbed me from my crib and took me out to the car, still wrapped up in blankets.
But then, just as my dad was about to start the car...
But everyone else would be like, ah!
And everyone in New Jersey would be like, what are you guys freaking out about?
Because on the car's radio, they were playing Bing Crosby tunes.
No matter what station he turned to, no one else seemed to be reporting on this big history.
So many people, I know a lot of people fell for it.
Sounds like something out of a big broadcast.
Have you guys heard of that one, like...
Nobody said a word.
It was like some program in...
My father and brother got off with a scolding from my mother, but I was the one who really suffered.
In the UK, I think?
After that incident, every time I acted up, my father and brother would scare me by saying, the Martians are coming!
That's terrible.
Isn't it?
Isn't it, though?
But it was like a ghost program.
I... I saw it.
But they played it off as like a...
So even nuclear weapons wouldn't work against the Martian war machines.
As like a real segment, like a real news thing.
Snake, if you conceal yourself like the Martians did, the enemy won't know what hit them.
I concealed myself.
Ghostwatch Live!
Maybe not immediately, but if you can hide yourself inside something a little more close at hand.
It's actually really interesting to watch, too.
Because they started like...
Something like...
A box!
Ah, I get it.
So...
You never saw the movie.
Sorry, I'm talking...
I saw it, alright?
But...
Sorry, I was talking all over that...
That codec.
But...
Yeah.
It's really interesting because like they played it off as like a normal kind of like live news documentary style thing.
And then like they started having creepy stuff happen in the studio as well.
And so people...
People trusted these like actual news act...
Not actors...
Anchors and stuff.
And...
So...
Then...
Like people were getting really, really freaked out about it.
It was...
It's...
So interesting.
La la la la la la la.
La la la.
My name is...
Snake.
And I'm...
Oh my god.
Carrot time!
Wait, where is he?
I'm a scientist.
I'm a scientist and I eat in...
In the slammer.
Oh wait.
Hello?
Sir, would you like a maroon shark?
Yummy.
I love looking at...
Haruna Yabuki.
You know?
Where is Sokolov again?
I don't remember.
Sokolov?
Sokolov, where are you?
Get the carrot time.
I haven't been getting him this entire time.
I'm not gonna start right now.
Wait, can I go under this bed?
What's in there?
Oh.
Wait a second.
I never knew this was here.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
The radio casters that did that were probably the first people to make an analog horror series without knowing it.
True though.
I'm in this jail cell.
Get me out, sir.
Oh my gosh.
What's in there?
Why does that guy not recognize me?
You don't know scientists?
You're not a scientist?
Why do you go...
Huh?
Okay.
Well.
Our coat's gonna be filthy after this trip.
True.
I believe there are a lot of people that get fooled by analog horror.
I mean, that's like a popular thing on TikTok actually is like, you know, because it's so easy to just make like a quick little something something and have it seem kind of like a realistic horror story.
And people actually do that quite often.
I like to watch them.
But sometimes they seem like quite realistic.
Right?
Like they seem like, Oh, this is this could be an actual horror something.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Oh my God.
Why do you have poisonous insects in your location?
Oh.
Wait, is it?
It's.
Let's see through here.
Forgot he pushes up his glasses when you do that.
Wait, isn't it through here?
How do I get them to go through here?
I'm looking for Sokolov, but isn't he in there?
Am I crazy?
He's not?
I'm crazy?
Where was he at again?
I can't remember.
Gotta go around the long way.
No!
Yeah, I gotta... Sokolov?
Sokolov?
Sokolov, are you there?
Where are you?
Hello, sir.
Hello, I'm just a scientist.
Doing my work.
My very important research.
Yeah.
So important.
Really, really, really, really important research.
Okay?
Like, don't bother me.
And also, I'm hungry.
Oh, wait!
Oh my gosh, I could blow this up.
I could blow this up.
It would be great.
Do it.
I'll forget about it, I swear.
I'll set the TNT and then forget.
Just like before.
Hello.
I'm not being suspicious.
I'm being very normal and average.
Oh, and I'm hungry.
What is that?
What is...
Oh, I've never...
seen that before.
It's like my first time ever seeing a...
a poster in this game that's not half-naked women.
That's insane.
What?
What's it for?
Let's have an instant noodles.
Actually, let's...
Oh, articulated python.
Where...
How...
How long have I had this?
I want some more.
I want some more!
Wow!
What a rare find!
Okay.
I feel like opening this is going to be scary, so...
Wait, can I go through here?
Into the unknown!
Oh.
Okay.
Where are we?
This place is a true maze.
Ten.
Chocolate chip!
Into the unknown!
Imagine a guy walking through scientist...
Through a scientist eating a articulated python.
Chocolate chip!
Just like me!
A little bit.
This is where some scientists are.
Oh my god!
Never mind.
That's a bathroom.
Okay.
That guy was not...
I lied?
Oh
my gosh.
Keto time.
I don't want to get caught by this bozo right here, you know?
Oh my gosh.
Do I go through here?
Hello.
Hello, sir.
Oh, hello.
I'm the reception scientist today.
That's my duty.
Don't mind me.
Just being a reception scientist.
I'm greeting all of our distinguished guests.
I'm gonna sneeze.
Oh my god.
I'm standing here because I'm gonna sneeze, officer.
At least I thought I was.
I lost the sneeze, officer.
I lost the sneeze.
Okay.
It's all stuffed up in my nose.
Before you say, what nose?
It's literally right there.
If you can't see it, you're blind.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Shit.
I hate these scientists.
Maybe I'll knock them out.
Oh my god.
Don't walk towards me.
Sorry.
I have wide arms.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
No!
Oh, wait.
Do I have to...
Oh, hold on.
They'll never know.
I
was really cool shoes.
I'm just...
Where are they shooting at?
Oh, my god!
Are you serious right now?
Oh, I have to not be in the disguise.
That's right.
I completely forgot.
Oh, shoot.
What are we gonna do?
How are we gonna get out of this mess?
How we get out of this mess?
Hmmm.
I'm not going to die.
Superchat was eaten by YouTube.
Oh no!
It denied intending to incite panic.
A funny cigarette?
No, I don't think... you get it...
Pretty sure you get that when you disguise yourself as that other guy.
What's his name?
Rykov.
I'm pretty sure that's when you go... when you get that thing.
Not that it matters what I'm wearing, but you know.
It's just a cardboard box in here!
Shit you.
Where are you?
Stop it!
I'm just a cardboard box in the corner of the room.
There's no reason you should know!
Okay?
Actually, since I'm here, and since you guys are down, we're gonna shut this door.
Actually, well, maybe not.
Okay, we're gonna just take you...
Wait, this is the right gun, right?
Yeah, okay.
We're just gonna... okay.
Don't wake up.
Okay?
And neither can you.
Don't wake up.
You're not allowed.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Ahem.
Sneak 100 something something.
Yeah.
This version is so great.
Ba-do-dang.
Ba-do-dang-dang.
Gotta turn it all the way up.
If you're looking for Sokolov, he's not here anymore.
Ugh!
Put that thing away.
You'll spoil my drink.
So, you're the intruder everyone's talking about.
Typical capitalist dog.
No manners.
You mean you've never heard of me?
And you call yourself an agent?
That photo on the wall.
That's insane.
Very well, then.
I am Aleksandr Leonovich Granin.
GRANIN!
A man of some importance, if I do say so myself.
I am the foremost weapon scientist in the Soviet Union.
And the head of the glorious Granin Design Bureau.
This is the Order of Lenin.
It is an honor of the greatest magnitude...
Sorry, I'm muting again so I can eat.
That's okay, we'll just watch the cutscene.
...the only and finest workers.
It was awarded to me in recognition of my brilliant contributions to society.
Since the Great Patriotic War, I have created countless weapons in the service of our great communist society.
Oh my god, Ray on the right!
It was thanks to me that we were able to stamp out the Nazi scum.
I never noticed the picture.
Maybe I just...
It was I who created the basic design for the mobile ballistic missile system you know and fear as SS1C.
The first time, why would you?
Yeah, I guess it's true.
But I've also watched, like, cutscenes of this.
I just never noticed it.
So, because of him, I've got nothing to do but sit here...
Maybe like a, you know, a half-watch.
...and drink this crap.
Him?
Sokolov!
It's him you're looking for, isn't it?
Yeah.
Because of him, I have been stripped of my authority.
My research has come to nothing.
Look!
It is a revolutionary mobile nuclear missile system.
Oh my god.
A bipedal tank.
Uh, oh.
I don't think we want that.
Ah!
A bipedal tank?
I don't think we want that.
Yes.
A walking tank.
A robot.
Who?
Who's asking for this?
Are you familiar with the theory of the missing link between apes and humans?
Well, this technology...
Yahoo!
The missing link between infantry and artillery.
A kind of metal gear, if you will.
Whoa!
He said the thing!
And this magnificent metal gear will mark a revolutionary step forward in weapons development.
Metal gear.
But I won't be used so easily.
No.
No crying myself to sleep.
Okay, I finally finished my piece of pizza.
You guys are safe.
For you see, I'm going to send these documents to my friend in the United States.
Oh my god, they show it so obviously.
That's so hilarious.
What?
Oh my god!
These bastards will live to regret this.
It's just Rex.
They may themselves become the targets of my creation.
They will know my true greatness.
Yes.
Sokolov's pathetic shagohan pales in comparison to my work.
I can't wait.
Oh my gosh.
What are you going to do with a rocket engine on a tank?
Yeah.
About Sokolov.
A tank does not need a rocket.
It needs something else.
It needs feet.
Look at these.
Nice shoes.
No.
Legs.
Legs that allow it to go anywhere.
Just as when humans learned to walk upright.
That is the real revolution in weaponry.
Don't you agree?
But the fool in charge shall Sokolov.
Oh god.
And where is Sokolov?
My project has been terminated.
The philosopher's legacy has been handed over to him.
What the hell are you talking about?
It's too good.
He's so dumb.
The philosopher's legacy.
Haven't you heard of the philosophers?
Such whimsy music.
The colonel has inherited their immense legacy.
Volgin's father was in charge of the philosopher's money and wealth.
He was in charge of all the laundering activities.
Oh.
In the confusion of the war, they somehow ended up with their treasure.
I think he should make some kind of T-Rex machine.
Volgin inherited that treasure illegally.
Yeah, I agree.
We never need to worry about the military budget.
The development costs at our facility are all paid out of the colonel's deep pockets.
Deep, deep pockets.
The weapons born here will be the genes for creating an entirely new form of warfare.
Are they talking about the Patriots?
This is pre-Patriots.
Funding for my research came out of that legacy.
Paid out of it.
Basically, yeah.
It's like proto-Patriots.
Now, my money, my men, all have been diverted to the Shag-O-Hod project.
Tomorrow, they will be conducting the final test.
While Sokolov is making the final preparations, in the weapons factory at Volgin's main base, the Great Fortress of Krasnigrad...
It's so funny if you think about it.
We destroyed the Shag-O-Hod.
So they're just like, you know what, let's go with Granon's plan instead.
It's our fault!
Of course.
They were like, oh wait a second, this guy's got like a good idea.
Are you mad?
It's an impenetrable fortress.
I'm sure it is.
Dang it.
You'll be killed.
I'll take my chances.
Wait.
Rex is way cooler too.
I know, right?
They have no taste.
Listen to me, you fool.
They like saw this and were just like, we don't want it to work.
Help me.
To thank you for your compliment.
What compliment?
Oh my god, he can't even remember.
My shoes.
Tatyana gave them to me.
I wanted to thank you for complimenting me on them.
Tatyana, Tatyana.
I'll tell you how to get into the fortress.
Okay.
Yeah, tell us.
In return, I ask only that you get that idiot out of there and destroy the Shagohan.
I can do that.
There is an underground tunnel that runs around the perimeter of the fortress.
Nice shoes.
You should be able to use it to sneak into the base.
One question, does it have a really long ladder?
Head to the mountains.
The entrance to the tunnel is located there.
Okay.
Take this.
Oh, what is that?
A bingo card.
You passed through a warehouse on your way here, didn't you?
Yeah, I even blew it up.
There should have been a locked door inside of it.
There what?
Do you remember it?
Uh...
This key will open that door.
A locked door?
Beyond that door lies a vast jungle.
Uh...
You can climb up into the mountains from the far end of the jungle.
Go back to the warehouse.
Use the key to open the locked door.
Isn't that the very front?
And head for the mountains.
The Russian jungles.
Got it.
Why are you helping me?
Unlike Sokolov, the thought of defecting has never once cleared my mind.
I trust my mind.
I love my country.
No.
I love this land.
I cannot even imagine living anywhere else.
I've blown it up a little times.
I wish to remain a hero.
Okay.
Of the great motherland.
They're like, that is Sokolov.
Traitorous.
Dog.
Being hounded into a corner and left to waste away.
It is already dawn.
Oh, wow.
Early.
You must hurry.
Okay.
I will remain here and nurse my troubles for a little longer.
We're about to fight.
Okay.
I think I remember now.
Capitalism.
Go home.
You're drunk, mister.
Be careful of what you do.
What was I saying?
In that trap area, isn't that where the fear is?
Now I remember.
Or think about it.
You think they'll notice if I turn back into a scientist.
Do you think they'll care if I'm a scientist again?
I gotta get out of this area, though.
Do you think they'll be like, hey, that's a great idea.
Who's the guy we were after?
Can
you let me out through your window?
So I can live in peace.
I just need an exit.
Okay...
But...
You guys, I wanna save.
Oh, I'm so scared to save!
To capitalism.
If I die though...
I can just start back at the same area.
I'm not knocking!
Right?
Like...
Do save one.
I'm too scared.
Okay.
If I die...
I just wanna...
I don't want to waste...
What's the words?
Oh my gosh.
Don't notice me.
I don't wanna waste materials, you know?
I'm just gonna run through.
Like if I get into a fight, you know?
I don't know.
I guess it's fine.
I get a lot.
Okay.
If I run past him...
He won't notice me.
Safe.
Safe!
Can I open this?
Nope.
You know what?
Let's just go back.
The way we came.
Okay.
No stinking doctors to...
ruin my time.
I think the cigarettes were in that barred window room.
I could have sworn the cigarettes are...
Wait, the office has the cig spray.
It does?
For real?
Wait, I could have sworn they were...
when you become...
Rykov.
No way.
If you miss them here...
Well, that would explain why I didn't get them before.
I just need this guy to leave.
Cig gas spray!
Waaah!
Oops, sorry.
Oh, my gosh!
Wow, thanks guys, I learned that.
Why do they all walk funny?
That's why I'm not out of place.
We're all just a little...
we all got really bad scoliosis here.
Excuse me.
I'm fine.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm scared of someone opening this door.
Someone else open it!
I'm afraid they're gonna be right there and they're gonna touch me and then I'm gonna get in trouble!
There it is.
Okay.
I'm just a little scientist in this room.
Another door opened.
Okay, now leave.
And I'll follow you.
You are so slow!
I'm slowly trying to get around you.
How did I come in?
Oh, maybe I should leave the same way I came in.
How do I... Okay, we go back through.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, I remember.
Yeah, I came in through the vent.
I think I'm gonna leave through the vent as well.
Excuse me!
Can't believe we kinda made that, actually.
Oh, my bad.
Huh.
You saw nothing!
Oh, oh, I forgot to...
Please.
Don't get caught, snake.
Snake.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
And... tiger's drop.
Uh...
Okay.
Thank you, mice.
I think the dog's awake and everybody.
I think everybody's awake now.
Beep, beep!
I hear someone.
Do I see them?
Not even a little bit.
Oh, there they are.
Good morning, gamers!
Y'all woke up from your nap?
Oh, my gosh.
He'll... he'll get caught.
It's fine.
Huh?
Yeah, exactly.
Ah, it's such a nice, bright, sunny morning.
The dawn of a new day.
It's beautiful outside.
We're just gonna crawl the way we came in.
Yup.
See you later, everybody.
Later, later.
Crocodiles.
I think I can loot this guy.
Give me what you got.
Nothing.
Okay.
Oh.
Look.
All right.
And back through our holes.
Nice.
Okay.
Now...
I'm going to...
What?
I'm too scared though, you guys.
Gosh, I'm scared.
I'm scared to save!
I'm so scared.
Do you want to save?
Let's do...
one.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Yes!
Snake, have you ever seen For a Fistful of Dollars?
Oh, paramedic, I've never been so happy to see you before ever.
Spaghetti Western.
Spaghetti!
It's really cool.
Especially the main character's stylish gunplay.
Gunplay.
I saw it in England on the Major's recommendation, but it hasn't come out on stage yet.
It's so cool.
They'll bring it to America, I'm sure.
You have to see it somewhere.
Sure.
I hear him.
I hear him, I just don't...
He's on his way.
How tall do you think he'll be?
Wait, is he behind me?
Okay.
Can you imagine?
He's right behind me...
Isn't he?
What did I just see?
One centimeter.
Hello?
I'm waiting for you.
I can't tell if he's...
There we go.
Snake, snake, snake!
This is no time for circles!
Okay, there we go.
Can I get the doll?
We'll get them from another spot.
Look at them!
They're teaming up!
The dog and the guy are teaming up.
We'll get him first.
Oh, there's two of them!
Oops.
I think?
Am I crazy?
The dog is confused.
Wait, can the dog wake him up?
I don't think so.
The dog says, I don't know, I'm a dog.
These are bizarre human shenanigans.
Okay.
I don't remember how this fight goes either, but let's do it, baby!
Thanks for the dog.
Oh my gosh.
My fears.
I'm actually afraid of needles.
An arrow is kind of like a thicker needle.
It's my real fear.
Ow!
We need to throw your Bulbocos, Snake.
Oh wait, that was your stomach.
That was also the fake mango.
We don't need any Bulbocos.
Ah,
the fear!
Eww!
Hahaha.
That throat is coated in the venom of the Brazilian wandering spider.
Oh.
Soon, a most exquisite pain will engulf your entire body.
Your limbs will be paralyzed.
Your lungs cease to draw breath.
Eventually, your heart will stop beating.
Ah, but what fun would that be?
Not a fitting day at all.
The boss's apprentice.
That's me.
I will give you fear such as you've never experienced before.
Come into my web.
It is time.
For you to feel the fear.
The fear.
Oh boy.
First we cure.
First we eat.
Let's have... you know what?
I'm gonna eat a cow... no.
Sorry, I'm trying to eat all my stuff that's gonna expire.
Which is... oh, okay, here we go.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna eat the best food.
Instant noodles!
Delicious.
Mmm, delicious.
I should have gotten more food.
You know what?
It's okay.
Uh... cure?
Serum?
Oh, N-R-E-O-O-N... okay, uh...
What do I do for this?
Mmm, gunshot wound?
Uh... cut?
Removing bullets and arrows!
Okay.
Now it's... the bolt is extracted, so now we just...
ViviCore, thanks for the gift card!
We do... d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-disinfect...
I don't wanna waste stuff.
Okay.
Disinfect.
Oh!
It works.
If you leave in... the bolts during the fight, they stay there for the rest of the game.
Wait, what do you mean?
Like... the bo- like...
The arrows?
Um... okay.
Ha- okay, so...
This is like a thermal goggle type of fight.
Cause he goes all invisible and all this fun stuff.
I don't remember the soundtrack at all.
Why does it sound like...
It sounds so...
It sounds like...
Like some Disney jungle theme.
What's the speedrun strat?
Speed... thermal goggles on temporarily when he's invisible.
Yeah, I'm gonna kill my eyes.
For real.
Are there...
I'm fear!
Ow!
Oh gosh.
That was close.
Fear!
Okay.
How the hell do I do this again?
Oh, I see him!
No!
Is he still there?
Oh yes he is.
Got him.
Oh, it did like...
The littlest, tiniest bit of damage ever.
That's okay.
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
Is he still there?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Turn around snake.
No!
I lost him.
I was too slow.
Can you save me?
I can actually.
Okay.
Shoot.
No!
Where did he go?
Your eyes cannot find me.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, okay.
He's there.
I see him.
Ouch!
No!
Shit.
Oh, hold on.
Let me also take off my...
Suppressor.
Oh my gosh.
Snake, how are you alive?
Snake!
Snake, how are you...
How are you alive, snake?
How did you live through this?
Oh my gosh.
It's like not even like a little bit deep.
It's like ultimate deep.
Snake, that's... that's a... that's a pretty big deal, buddy.
I think that's a big... that's a big thing going on.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I can see you, kind of.
I'm afraid of you attacking me, though.
There we go.
He just left again.
Oh, I see him.
Oh, he's in my tree?
Oh, gross.
I gotta be faster.
Oh, fuck.
I keep getting a bad angle.
Wait, where is he?
There he is.
Okay.
Ouch!
It does like so little damage to him.
Ew, I hate when he does this.
Oh, can I see him?
Can I see him?
Oh.
Yeah!
I see him.
That is him.
Oh.
Oh, just kidding.
Holy moly.
Where is he?
Actually, I don't know where he is at all.
Oh my gosh.
Where is it coming from?
Oh?
Where is it?
Oh.
I'm like using sound.
There!
Got
him a couple times.
Oh, my bad.
I don't know where he shot at.
He's like a Pokmon.
Oh!
Shit, shit, shit!
Ew!
Son of a bitch.
Where did she go?
Usually, I can see him like swinging from the trees.
So, it's not all bad.
Wherever he is now, though.
Where the hell is he?
Ow!
Oh.
There we go.
I don't think I got him.
Please!
Damn it.
Damn, don't go.
I don't like this spot that you go into.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Wait.
Snake, I need you to like look at the place that I'm looking at, okay?
Where did he go?
Shh.
Sorry, I'm gonna have to have it on.
What's the original camera like?
Oh, let's check it out.
Give me a second there.
Oh.
Please.
Oh, my god.
I'm gonna need more bullets soon.
No.
He's really scaring me.
He's scaring me.
Shotgun works too?
Oh, maybe I should do that then instead.
Oh, there he is.
I thought for sure he would stop there.
Hey,
this is awful.
Okay, hold on.
Let's add the shotgun.
If you catch him on the ground when he's getting food.
Yeah, the shotgun only works in a really short range.
I know.
Oh, AK?
Okay, let's see.
Let's put this away.
Okay.
Put this away.
Would the M16 be any good?
I can take away.
We'll just have all three.
Most likely I'll run out of ammo for something.
You know.
We don't...
I don't...
I think the SPD...
I think it'll be okay.
Okay.
No AK stun.
I don't actually know the cheese for this, I'll be honest.
I don't know it.
Hold in first person view.
Let's try it.
Wait, what is it?
Toggle firing load with...
With the triangle button.
There's a...
You can get a suppressor for this?
Huh.
I actually get the suppressor.
I didn't hit him though!
I did hit him!
Oh
shoot!
Blast him!
Did I even get that much?
I didn't check.
Oh!
Actually, okay I'm out.
Okay.
I'll take it.
I don't know where he is.
There he is.
What are you doing over there?
I think he was over there.
Oh there he is, yeah.
Where's this one?
Where'd he go?
I have to watch out for traps even.
I got him!
Where'd he go?
I'm losing track of him.
Oh my gosh.
Oh yeah baby!
Ouch!
You bastard!
A grenade?
Oh my god.
Oh I'm out of ammo!
Shoot.
I'm out of ammo.
Sorry.
I forgot what I needed to do.
Okay.
Let's do... AK.
Baby.
Oh I see him.
Oh my god!
No!
How did we...
Okay.
I'm gonna have to keep it on.
I'm sorry guys.
OUCH!!
Where are you?
Fuck.
I feel like I'm gonna die you guys.
I feel like I'm gonna die.
I can't... I need to heal faster.
Um.
I'm going to eat a calorie meat.
He said dodge, he didn't dodge.
I was trying to find him.
I don't know where to dodge.
How can I dodge if I don't know where to dodge?
Oh wait, what is the LF Med?
What's that?
Wait, what's that?
Where do you guys even say that?
In the backpack.
It's an idol.
When did I get this?
Wait.
Like the life medicine?
Oh my gosh.
I kept thinking this was the revival pill.
Wait, I thought...
Because it's like, oh yeah, it brings you back to life.
Okay, goodbye cigar.
Life medicine.
Let's try it out.
I'm scared though, because he does a lot of damage.
No, no, no.
Oh
my gosh.
To be fair, life medicine sounds like a revival.
Okay.
Shoot.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Where are you?
Oh my god, how did that get me?
No way, I was behind the tree.
Are you kidding me?
I just used my thing.
Wait.
I just...
I just used my life medicine and you do this to me.
Oh, I got to get it out.
It's hard to go from this to getting my bearings back to him.
I think that's the issue I'm having with him.
Okay.
Are you feeling the fear, Vito?
Yeah, I'm feeling the fear.
I'm feeling the fear.
I just got to get him a few more times.
A little bit more.
I can't move.
That's an issue.
I can't move around too much because there's so many traps in this one.
There's so many traps here.
It's not even fair.
There's traps.
Maybe I should have gotten rid of them.
Could I have gotten rid of them before I got here?
I never thought about that.
Glad to see you playing this game.
Been a fan of yours a long time.
This is my first donation.
Thank you.
Hope you have an amazing future in streaming.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I think they respawn.
Lame.
Okay.
I know where...
I thought I knew where...
Okay.
Oh.
Where...
What is he doing?
What?
Where is he?
Damn.
Oh.
It's my turn.
Oh, he's so close.
Wait.
Oh.
Shit.
I'm just...
Spry
babies!
Spry on Spry!
The fear!
I see it!
Why was he filled with arrows?
Everybody, that should be a new party trick for funerals.
When you die, fill your body with arrows.
And then, when your family has the funeral, just say, SURPRISE!
Looks like the fear spent too much of his own Brazilian wandering spider venom.
Yeah, I did.
Oh, there's the bunny.
Defeats... like a super spider man cannot defeat a little bunny.
Okay.
I got a serum for that too!
Interesting.
Interesting, interesting, interesting.
Are there still booby traps?
I'm scared.
You could be an unhinged weirdo, jumping around, climbing trees, saying anything you want, so long as you're good at your job.
Yeah, so true.
Okay, be careful.
He probably ate a frog!
Idiot!
Oh, maybe because I killed a frog, he was like, yummy, and then he ate it, and then he was just like...
I can get that bird.
You guys, I can get this bird.
Got him.
I got that bird.
And there's another magazine!
Let's take it.
Was the shotgun necessary?
Ribbit, ribbit, ribbit.
I think I have to go this way.
To go back to the place that we came from.
What is that trap?
Hello?
If you walk through this trap a...
Huh?
A rope will give you a bump on your head.
A sausage.
That's here too.
Wait, I saw it.
I swear.
There!
But when I turn around...
It's gone.
It's a ghost.
Kero-tan!
Oh my gosh, I found him.
Ghost rope.
How do I get back up here?
Boy.
I
thought about that too when we were like...
Coming here.
That's north where you came from?
Go south?
Oh, are you sure?
Oh.
Okay.
I believe you.
Okie dokie.
I'm stalking.
So I don't...
You know.
So I don't meet an unsatisfactory fate.
Oh my gosh.
Rope.
I'm stalking.
Okay.
Oh!
There it is.
Alright.
Let's get our...
inventory ready again.
I am going to be...
ending...
soon.
We go...
through...
Like I said, I don't want to get to the end.
The boss, the end.
Once I go through the...
door in the other place.
Is that the key?
Is that where he's at?
You said you were ending three hours ago.
No!
I said if I...
I said about my...
My...
What's it called?
My save.
If it didn't work.
But it worked.
Yes, but there's a buffer area.
Okay.
You go through the door and then another...
Okay, perfect.
We'll go through the door.
And I'll save.
And it'll hopefully...
work.
And if not, I'll just leave it on.
And I'll go find my other...
Um...
What's it called?
My other...
Thing.
But we will...
go defeat that guy.
Thank you, my show.
Memory card.
Yeah.
Sorry.
You guys, I'm not articulate...
at all.
I can't ever think of anything.
I can't ever think of words.
Words are so difficult.
Words are so hard.
Munchies!
Oh my god.
They're desperate for food.
They're desperate for food!
Munchies!
What is he eating?
Don't take my food.
Munchies!
Wait, I can't move.
Snake.
Just crawl forward.
There we go.
Munchies!
I'm so hungry.
This is so sad!
No!
I destroyed all their food and now they're starving!
Let me...
Let me change.
See if I can...
change my camel.
Oh, splitter.
I like the splitter one.
I think I like the splitter one the most.
Give them my poisonous dart.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Munchies!
This poor...
Poor group of guys, man.
If I throw it...
Well, wait, my poison dart...
Wait, I can't throw it though.
Because it's not...
alive, right?
Wait, hold on.
Yeah.
I can only dispose of him, right?
There's that guy there.
Okay, hold on.
I don't want him to see that other dude I just took out.
Hold on, there we go.
Hold on.
Please shoot!
There we go.
My gosh.
Sometimes the trigger...
is so cruel to me.
Or the controller.
Okay, so I know there's a guy...
over here.
Are you the hungry guy?
Are you the hungry, hungry hippo?
No, no, no!
Fuck!
Shit!
I let go!
Oh my god.
I let go, for real.
This is so cruel!
This damn...
controller sometimes!
It's so sticky, I swear!
Yes!
Stay down!
Gosh!
Was there anybody... there was another guy, wasn't there?
Over that way?
In front of the door?
I'm almost positive there is.
Unless he's just not...
going around.
Yeah, paused.
Can't see him though.
I don't know.
They showed a guy in front of the door...
but it could've just been for dramatic effect.
Can't remember.
I guess that's it.
Okay, cool.
Food in the weapon section for throwing?
Oh, okay.
Sorry guys, sometimes I'm looking at...
the game and I'm not looking at chat.
If you're just like trying to tell me something.
Sometimes...
I'm...
I'm gaming.
Sometimes.
You know how it is.
You know how it is, right?
When you're like gaming.
Are the control sticks and buttons...
getting weirdly sticky?
Like, rotting away?
Oh, I hope not.
I don't... I don't sure hope not.
Come on, get the crab!
Get the crab!
Oh, my food is full?
Oh, I thought I was hungry.
Just kidding.
Okay, you know what?
Let's just go.
I'm still weary.
Just kidding.
All good.
Crab battle.
Serum.
Antidote.
Good, good, good, good.
Alright.
Th...
Gordon...
Alright.
Okie dokie.
Now I can save.
Okay.
Yeah, it's time to...
Oops.
No, I think I'm good.
Thank you.
Thank you, Major.
Do you want to save?
Yes.
Yes, but I'm scared, paramedic, please.
Paramedic, I'm scared.
I'm scared, paramedic.
Paramedic, I'm scared!
I'm scared, paramedic!
I'm scared, paramedic.
I'm scared.
Yippee!
Snake, have you seen the movie Them?
Then.
No.
It's about these giant ants Oh, my God.
She loves monster movies.
after a nuclear test.
She tries to fight them off with flamethrowers.
The ants were so big that they filled up the entire screen.
The whole movie theater was screaming.
An ant that big could make a good meal.
Yeah.
Well, if you find any, don't eat them.
Come on.
They're not that bad for you.
Yay!
If you end up growing huge like that, you won't have any place left to hide.
Just like a girlagon.
What is a... a what?
A girlagon?
Snake, what the hell is that?
What is that?
Alrighty.
So, when we come back...
Maybe next week I'll do a mid-day...
No, I'll do it on Saturday.
No, wait.
I can't do it...
I'll probably do a mid-day Metal Gear.
Or like a mid-week, rather.
Mid-week Metal Gear.
Next week.
So...
Probably like the day after I celebrate my birthday.
I'm gonna be celebrating my birthday on...
October 2nd.
My birthday's on the 1st.
But I'm gonna be celebrating on the 2nd.
I have announcements.
I have...
Well, announcement.
I have an announcement.
So...
If you are so inclined to come celebrate my birthday with me and some friends...
I think it'll be a fun time.
I worked really hard on getting stuff set up for it.
I'm not quite done.
So actually, right after the stream, I'm gonna be working and recording stuff more.
So...
It is a good announcement.
I'm very excited.
So, yeah.
It's a good announcement.
No worries, no worries, no worries.
No worries at all.
Zero worries.
In fact, be hype for it, please.
Please clap.
Please buy or use a new PS2 memory card.
Yes, I will.
Make sure that there's...
Or not make sure, but I will try a different memory card next stream so that...
Actually, probably, I'm just gonna leave it like this and save this save onto the next new memory card.
So I'm gonna go find it and do all that good stuff.
Yeah, I was feeling a little under the weather today.
No, I feel better!
Feel better.
I probably will go out and buy a new memory card as well.
Oh my gosh, I wonder if I can get one in Japan.
You think that basic is so expensive?
Hmm...
This week, I am going back to Japan.
It's not a very long trip.
I'm going to TGS.
Tokyo Game Show.
So, yes, I will be attempting to try the demo of Delta.
Yes, I will tell you guys all about it if I can try and all that fun stuff.
And...
Yeah.
So...
You can get Minto's first-hand experience.
Yeah, I'm trying to get the crawl cards.
A souvenir?
Yeah, a souvenir.
Yeah, so...
But I will be streaming tomorrow and the day after.
So Monday, Tuesday.
And then I will be back...
I will be back on the 2nd.
What day is that?
Wednesday?
Yes.
So basically, gone for a week.
And then it will be happy tomorrow, right?
Oh, yes, thank you for reminding me.
Oh my gosh, Platypus, thank you.
I have an official happy coat.
I don't have a picture with me right now, I'm sorry.
I have an official happy coat that will be starting pre-order tomorrow.
But...
Google says you shouldn't need to worry about region logs on PS2 memory cards.
Oh, okay.
I was going to actually just look that up right after this.
Thank you, Nano.
Cat approved.
Yes, it is cat approved.
It's really, really soft.
It's quite a soft, sturdy material.
So it's really nice.
It's made to order.
It's not limited stock.
And the pre-orders, I believe, are open for three weeks?
I will double-check that.
Yeah.
So it's made to order.
And it won't sell out, so don't worry if you're just like, Oh my gosh, I can't wake up at that time!
Or whatever.
Just order within the time period and you'll all be good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
Wait for a week while I have a week off so I can actually catch more livestreams.
Oh, sorry, Sean!
Yeah, um...
Sorry.
But if you needed to catch up on some Minto streams, you can do that.
And also...
Yeah, it should be my last time traveling for like...
especially to Japan this year.
Um...
I have another trip at the end of the year.
I want to go to Komiket.
But that's like, basically...
2025.
So...
X to doubt.
No, please.
I'm actually so...
tired of traveling.
I'm so tired of flying.
And it's so expensive!
It's very, very expensive.
But this is an important trip for me.
Truly, I really, really wasn't going to go.
But um...
an event is happening that's basically forcing me.
It's forcing my hand.
It's a last time opportunity ever, ever, ever for this.
So I have to go.
And I get to go to TGS as well.
So I will be filming that and I'll edit that once I'm back and show you guys.
How fun it was and all the cool stuff that there was.
Sorry, that sounds so mean.
I'm going to show you guys how fun this place was and make you sad that you couldn't go.
No, I'm just kidding.
This is the double Oshii plus TGS Japan trip, right?
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
Double Oshii TGS.
Yeah.
But no, if you've never been to TGS too maybe we'll show you kind of a good idea of what it's like as well.
I've only been once.
And I went during like the public day.
It's hellish.
It's absolutely hellish.
It's... Honestly, if I could not go to TGS and you know, just watch videos of it, I would.
It's... I'm not...
I'm not...
I'm so scared of the Metal Gear booth.
I'm actually really terrified of the Metal Gear booth.
Because it's Delta, like last year it was the it was the Master Collection.
And those are games that, you know, you could still play.
This is a brand new Metal Gear game.
So I'm terrified.
I'm terrified if I will one, be able to play it because um basically the way they do it is you go up to the booth and they give you a number ticket.
And that will say like come back between 12pm to 1pm and you can play the game.
You line up and you play the game between that time slot.
But they hand them all out at the very beginning of the day.
So if I get there even like 10 minutes late um it's gonna it could possibly all be out.
So um I'm going to do my best.
I'm going to do my best.
Because I definitely was not able to do the Master Collection last year because of that.
Yeah.
Sounds stressful to be honest.
I know!
And honestly I'm like I'm like not I'm not saying that I'm not looking forward to it obviously.
But I'm just nervous about it.
I've been so nervous I'm just like oh what if I travel all the way there and I don't even get to play it.
You know?
So I'm really I'm really nervous about it.
I'm like what if it will be such a waste.
Hmm.
Um but yeah.
We'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
Praying.
I especially want to tell you guys all about it too.
Because I hate those stinky IGN articles or like the load times and it still showed the the What do you mean it's not open world?
No I want to tell you guys how good it is and you know how fun it is and everything.
I don't want some bozo out there being like I played Metal Gear when I was 7 years old and blablabla blablabla Game articles or journalist articles can be negative.
Yeah.
I want us to have.
I want us to you know I want to just talk about how fun it is and how cool it is.
Even though I don't know.
What if I hate it?
Oh my gosh.
What if I'm just like I can't wait to tell you guys about how much I love it and how awesome of an experience it is and I play it and I'm like ugh.
They were right.
What if I'm like it was the worst experience ever.
No Konami don't listen.
Konami I'm sure I'm going to love it.
I'm going to love it okay.
Yeah.
2 out of 10 too much reloading.
Oh gosh.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to go now.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me.
If I see you sometime this week.
Which would really only be Monday or Tuesday.
I will see you then.
And if not then I'll see you when I get back for my birthday.
Literally.
Literally I'm getting back and I'm like birthday time.
Birthday.
Thanks for the thumbnail art.
Thank you so much.
I love the thumbnail art.
It's so awesome.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for the long stream.
Yeah.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Um.
Yeah.
So I'm coming back and it's immediate birthday bash extravaganza.
So.
Akidoki.
Thank you guys.
And I'll see you guys later.
Bye bye.
Thank you.
See you.